Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Je älter, umso stärker müssen die Spieler auch darauf vorbereitet werden, dass Fußball eine Ergebnissportart ist. Aber der Druck, gewinnen zu müssen, darf nie größer sein als der Spaß und die Freude. Die Egoversuchungen durch Ruhm und Reichtum, die sind schon extrem groß. Naja, aber du musst ja nicht zum Arschloch werden, nur weil du in dem Alter oder als Profi bekannt bist, Autogramme schreiben darfst. Ja, ich glaube, dass wir Trainer mehr denn je die Pflicht haben, nicht nur Technik, Taktik, Kondition, mentale Stärke und Teamfähigkeit zu vermitteln, sondern mehr denn je wichtige traditionelle Werte, wie zum Beispiel Respekt, Dankbarkeit, Demut.
Leroy Sané, Mesut Özil, Manuel Neuer, Benedikt Höwedes, Julian Draxler, Sejan Kolasinac und noch viele, viele mehr – sie alle sind durch die Hände von Norbert Elgert gegangen. U19-Trainer bei Schalke 04 und ziemlich sicher einer der bekanntesten Nachwuchstrainer Deutschlands. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem Tribünengespräch Nummer 35. Mein Name ist Max-Akob Ost. Ich bin der Gehnetzer bei Twitter und hatte die Freude, Norbert Elgert interviewen zu dürfen. Er hat ein Buch über sein Leben geschrieben. Es heißt, gib alles nuni auf. Erschien es im Arrest von Verlag und mithilfe des Journalisten Kai Psotter. Und wir haben genau dieses Buch zum Anlass genommen, ihn zu treffen und über sein Leben, seine Arbeit und seine Gedanken zum deutschen Nachwuchsfußball zu sprechen. Dieses Gespräch folgt gleich hier im Anschluss. Vorher bedanke ich mich aber noch bei Markus Schwemmer, Christine Turboris, Filo Florian und Max aus München benichtigt selbst. Wer sind diese Menschen, fragt ihr euch vielleicht. Das alles sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe- paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über die Freiwilligen. Unterstützungen unserer Supporterinnen und Supporter. Wer mehr dazu erfahren möchte, kann das tun auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen gibt es alle Informationen, wie man den Rasenfunk finanziell unterstützen kann und damit dieses Projekt hier am Leben erhalten. Und wer uns unterstützt, der kann sich dann auch registrieren im sogenannten Rasenfunk-Supporters-Club. Diesen Club verwenden wir vor allem dafür, um uns auch immer wieder bei euch zu bedanken, bei allen Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützern des Rasenfunks. Und in diesem hier vorliegenden Fall haben wir sogar eine Kleinigkeit, die wir euch zukommen lassen können. Der Ariston-Verlag hat uns freundlicherweise ein Exemplar des Buchs von Norbert Elgert zur Verfügung gestellt, das wir verlosen unter euch Supporterinnen und Supporter draußen. Wenn ihr Supporterinnen und Supporter seid und euch registriert habt, dann habt ihr in dieser Sekunde schon eine E-Mail bei euch im Postfach. In der ist alles beschrieben, wie ihr in dieser Verlosung teilnehmen könnt. Es läuft noch eine ganze Weile, bis zum Saisonbeginn habt ihr noch Zeit, an der Verlosung teilzunehmen. Alle Informationen bekommen die registrierten Supporterinnen und Supporter über diese E-Mail. Viel Glück euch allen! Jetzt würde ich sagen, gehen wir rein in das Gespräch. Ursprünglich war es mal geplant, in der Lobby eines Hotels in unmittelbarer Nähe an der Arena auf Schalke. Da waren dann aber die akustischen Bedingungen so, dass Norbert Elgert gesagt hat, ne, also das mach mal anders. Und dann saßen wir am Ende in seiner Trainerkabine, in der kleinen U19-Trainerkabine. Es ist ein bisschen so, wie man es sich vorstellt, spartanisch, alles auf Fußball reduziert, hat große Freude gemacht, auch genau an diesem Ort die Folge aufzunehmen. Und ich hoffe, das Gespräch, das dabei herausgekommen ist, bereitet euch auch Freude. Legen wir los. Viel Spaß mit dem Gespräch mit Norbert Elgert, U19-Trainer von Schalke 04. Herr Elgert, wir sind hier in der Trainerkabine auf Schalke. Ich durfte quasi ins Allerheiligste, herzlichen Dank dafür. Erzählen Sie mir doch mal ein bisschen, wo wir uns hier befinden, jetzt gar nicht so sehr vom Trainingsgelände hier, sondern von der Gegend. Wie ist das Ruhrgebiet? Wie sind die Leute hier drauf? Erzählen Sie mir ein bisschen von der Gegend.
Von der Gegend. Ja, wir sind hier sicherlich in einem. Ich bin ja gebürtiger Gelsenkirchener in Gelsenkirchen-Ickendorf geboren. Das ist hier so Luftlinie, so Pi mal Daumen, 5, 6, 7 Kilometer. Wir sind hier im Stadtteil Buhr, ein sehr schöner Stadtteil von Gelsenkirchen. Nebenan der Berger See, ein großer See mit ganz viel Wald um den See herum. Also ein großes Waldgebiet würde man hier in Gelsenkirchen gar nicht vermuten. Aber auch Gelsenkirchen ist mit den Jahrzehnten deutlich schöner geworden. Wir sind hier ein Kilometer vom Berger See entfernt auf dem Schalker Vereinsgelände. Das ist gerade schwer umgebaut und modernisiert. Es passiert hier gerade sehr viel in der Infrastruktur. Wir bekommen große Bürogebäude, vor allen Dingen aber einige Fußballplätze mehr. Einige sind schon entstanden, einige sind gerade noch im Bau. Wir befinden uns hier gerade in der nicht ganz so modernen U19-Trainerkabine. Aber wir haben hier alles, was wir brauchen. Wir haben hier Stühle, wir haben Bänke, wir haben eine Taktik-Tafel.
Genau, die habe ich gerade als erstes gesehen.
Wir haben sogar für jeden Trainer hier einen Spind. Wir haben natürlich auch noch andere Räume, um moderne Medien nutzen zu können.
Und das ist jetzt quasi unsere unmittelbare Umgebung. Ich habe schon das 4231 gleich gesehen. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie aktuell das alles schon ist. Aber erzählen Sie mir noch ein bisschen was von der Gegend. Ich komme selbst aus der Provinz Bayerns, habe in Freiburg studiert und bin dann nach München gezogen. Deswegen habe ich mit dem Ruhrgebiet keine wirklichen Assoziationen, außer so ein bisschen der Dinge, die so klischeehaft fast überliefert sind. Wie würden Sie denn das Ruhrgebiet beschreiben? Naja, das Arbeitermilieu, dass man hier auch sehr direkt ist, das glaube ich auch schon erkannt zu haben bei Besuchen hier in der Gegend, dass man sehr offen zueinander ist. Das sind so die Dinge, die ich jetzt damit assoziieren würde. Aber dann hört es schon relativ bald auf. Was verbinden Sie denn mit der Region?
Ja, das ist zunächst mal auch meine Kindheit. Ich bin in Gelsenkirchen-Ickendorf großgeworden. Ein Arbeiterviertel, die meisten Menschen, die da gelebt haben, das hat sich inzwischen auch sehr verändert, waren Bergleute oder Handwerker, so wie in meiner Familie zum Beispiel mein Onkel Paul, der Maschinenschlosser war, mein Vater Heinz, der später Bezirk Schornsteinfeger, Meister war, aber Schornsteinfeger gelernt hat. Die Menschen hier im Ruhrgebiet sind sehr offen und ehrlich, sind aber auch – das hängt wahrscheinlich auch mit der Tradition, mit der Herkunft zusammen. Gerade in der Nachkriegszeit ist hier sehr viel zerstört gewesen, gerade im Ruhrgebiet in Gelsenkirchen. Also die Menschen hier sind gewohnt, die Ärmel aufzukrempeln.
Und merkt man das heute auch noch?
Das sollte man merken. Sie haben jetzt wahrscheinlich auf den Fußball angespielt. Das ist heute immer noch so. Auf den Fußball bezogen, wenn Sie mich jetzt angesprochen hätten. Normalerweise hier bei uns auf Schalke ja. Die nächste Frage wäre wahrscheinlich irgendwann in die Richtung gegangen, ob das bei unserer Profimannschaft im letzten Jahr auch der Fall war. Sagen wir mal so, es war im letzten Jahr nicht so deutlich zu erkennen, wie man es eigentlich erkennen muss, dass du nämlich nach jedem Spiel als Profi-Fußballer im Grunde genommen – ich übertreibe da – ein klein wenig vom Platz getragen werden musst, weil du so kaputt bist, weil du so hart gearbeitet hast, weil du so viel gelaufen hast, weil du so viel gekämpft hast.
Ich sehe schon, Sie haben die Züge gerne in der Hand. Sie nehmen auch meine Interviewführung so ein bisschen vorweg.
Um Himmels willen.
Nein, nein, alles gut. Das ist sehr positiv. Aber lassen Sie uns noch kurz eben bei Ihrer Kindheit bleiben, weil Sie da eben auch in Ihrem Buch, gibt alles nur nie auf, sehr ausführlich darüber schreiben und weil das ja so auch ein bisschen den Hörern und Hörern vermittelt, was für ein Mensch sie sind und was für ein Trainer sie dann auch daraus geworden ist. Wie hat sich denn Gelsenkirchen verändert in der Zeit? Sie sind 1957 zur Welt gekommen. Wie war es denn damals?
Ich habe ja nur in den ersten neuen Lebensjahren hier gelebt und arbeite hier jetzt schon eine Ewigkeit wieder. Aber durch den Beruf meines Vaters, der dann seinen eigenen Bezirk bekam, das war dann in Westerkappeln bei Osnabrück, sind wir dann hier weggezogen. Von daher habe ich die Veränderung nicht so permanent verfolgen können, als wäre ich die ganze Zeit hier dabei gewesen. Wie war Gelsenkirchen damals? Wie war Gelsenkirchen-Ickendorf damals? Für uns war das ja schon eine Stadt für sich. In dem Alter siehst du die Dinge ja ganz anders. Und Schalke war von Anfang an natürlich dann schon uns sehr präsent, sehr bewusst und auch von Anfang an so der Lieblingsverein. Wobei es in Gelsenkirchen viele andere große Vereine gab und gibt. Hier in SC Hassel oder damals war es Eintracht Gelsenkirchen, so bei uns in der Nähe. Ja, wie habe ich das wahrgenommen? Bergmannstraße 39 haben wir gewohnt, Oberster Stock. Das habe ich auch schon öfter angedeutet. Drei-Zimmer-Wohnung für zwei Erwachsene, vier Kinder. Keine Badewanne, keine Toilette. Aber wir hatten immer genügend zu essen und zu trinken. Einmal, weil unsere Eltern uns natürlich schon entsprechend versorgt haben, da alles gegeben haben eben auch. Und die Großeltern in der Nähe wohnten, komme ich gleich noch mal darauf zurück. Vor der Haustür, vielleicht 50 Meter Luftlinie, war dann auch schon der Bolzplatz. Und das war natürlich für uns ganz wichtig, weil Fußball war damals noch mehr wie heute die absolute Sportart Nummer eins und war natürlich auch für uns eine Möglichkeit, uns auszutun. Damals gab es diese Bolzplätze, diese Möglichkeit noch deutlich häufiger und in einer größeren Anzahl als heute. Und da bin ich dann eben schon sehr früh gestanden an dem Platz. Und das hat dann – ich beschreibe es ja auch so ein bisschen mit meinem Buch – schon eine ganze Zeit gedauert, bis ich dann irgendwann mal mitspielen durfte. Ich war mit vier Jahren stand ich da und es hat schon den ein oder anderen Monat gedauert, bis ich dann das erste Mal mitmachen durfte. Wie war das Ruhrgebiet? Wir konnten uns austoben. Wir hatten Spielplätze, es waren Sportplätze in der Nähe und da hat man natürlich sehr früh dann die Möglichkeit genutzt, von oben aus der Wohnung rauszukommen auf die Straße und zu toben und zu spielen und zu klettern und zu springen. Aber eben auch sehr viel Fußball gespielt.
Gut, dann sind sie ja am Fußball auch quasi als Sportart gar nicht vorbeigekommen, wenn das so direkt vor ihrer Haustür war. Gab es denn auch einen Moment, wo sie dann gesagt haben, das ist so richtig auch mein Spiel? Also gibt es einen Grund, warum sie jetzt noch ihr ganzes Leben dem Fußball widmen?
Ja, ich habe dem Fußball natürlich unglaublich viel zu verdanken, gar keine Frage, weil es gibt nicht viele Dinge, die ich richtig gut kann. Dazu gehörte Fußball spielen, Fußball coachen und mit Menschen umgehen können, viel mehr nicht. Das reicht aber, um in diesem Leben ganz gut klarzukommen. Plus natürlich meine Familie, vor allen Dingen meine Frau. Nee, ich hatte mich aber vom ersten Moment angepackt. Ich kann mich da nicht mehr so daran erinnern. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ich habe vom ersten Moment gewusst, das ist mein Spiel. Es gab gar nichts anderes. Alle Kinder aus der Nachbarschaft haben den ganzen Tag gebolzt und haben gespielt. Es gab gar keine Alternative. Es hat mir wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht, mit dem Ball umzugehen. Aber auch dann dieses Spiel zu spielen. Also eine Alternative. Ich wäre, glaube ich, in anderen Sportarten auch ganz okay gewesen. Aber eine echte Alternative zum Fußball gab es da eigentlich nie.
Scorsche hat ja später noch mal eine Rolle gespielt in ihrer Biografie.
Ja, und dann gab es ja dann irgendwann auch die Straßenspiele, die den Vereinsfußball ersetzt haben. Ich bin erst mit neun Jahren angefangen im Verein zu spielen in Westakappeln mit meinem älteren Bruder damals. Und diese Spiele auf der Straße oder der Straßenmannschaften gegeneinander, das waren unsere Matches. Und das war dann eben kein Elf gegen Elf, das war mal Fünf gegen Fünf, das war mal Sechs gegen Sechs, das war mal Acht gegen Acht. War aber auch vielleicht mal Unterzahl, Überzahl, weil es nicht so hinkam, sodass wir damals diese typische Bolzplatzmentalität, die man ja heute vermisst, einfach von vornherein zu Genüge hatten.
Und dann ist das ja auch genau das Alter, wenn man als Kind Fußball spielt. Als Kind hat man es noch leichter zu träumen und hat große Vorstellungen, wo das alles mal hinführen könnte. Ich finde den Unterschied ganz interessant zwischen ihrer Biografie und zum Beispiel Biografien von anderen Fußballern oder Fußballpersönlichkeiten, die aus einer Generation früher kommen. Also zum Beispiel Franz Beckenbauer, Overrad, Vogts, Klaus Fischer auch. Die sind alle in einer Zeit mit dem Fußball sozialisiert worden, die noch direkt mit der Nachkriegszeit zu tun hatte. Und für die, wenn man deren Biografien liest, da hatte der Fußball immer so eine eskapistische Form, und zwar in zwei Formen. Und zwar zum einen in der Kindheit, wo es meistens so war, sobald man aus dem Elternhaus raus war, also quasi räumlich draus war, dann hatte man relativ wenig Kontrolle und konnte dann sich auch in dieses Spiel flüchten. Und dann aber auch bei allen relativ früh dann in der Jugend auch so ein bisschen als die Möglichkeit, aus den eigenen Verhältnissen heraus sich zu entwickeln, weil der Fußball auf einmal Biografien wiedergeschrieben hat in Deutschland mit den 54ern Weltmeistern und dadurch, dass dann auch langsam mehr Geld in den Fußball kam, war das auf einmal eine Option, über den Fußball auch sich quasi aus den eigenen Verhältnissen herauszuarbeiten und das als Beruf wahrzunehmen. Jetzt habe ich mir die Frage gestellt in der Vorbereitung, wie unterscheiden sich solche Biografien von Ihrer Biografie?
Ich kenne diese Biografien nicht, also von daher kann ich nur von mir sprechen. Also Fußball als große Lebenschance, das hat sich bei mir erst später entwickelt. Also ich glaube, dass all die Spieler, Franz-Klaus Fischer, mit dem ich ja selber zusammengespielt habe, einer der besten Mittelstürme aller Zeiten, dass sie alle schon einen ähnlichen Weg gegangen sind. Sie sind ja auch alle angefangen, Fußball zu spielen, weil Fußball das schönste Spiel der Welt ist, weil es so viel Spaß macht. Ich glaube, keiner von ihnen ist angefangen, Fußball zu spielen, ist auf den Platz gegangen und hat davon geträumt, dass er dadurch seinen Status später anheben kann, dass er Millionen verdienen kann. Die sind alle angefangen, genau wie ich, weil das eben so wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht. Und dann kommt es ja mit den Jahren, wenn du drei, vier, fünf Jahre da stehst und spielst, oder der eine früher oder der andere später, dass sich der Traum Profi-Fußball entwickelt, dass aus diesem Traum dann irgendwann mal ein brennender Wunsch, ein Burning Desire entsteht und dass aus diesem Wunsch dann irgendwann auch mal das große Ziel wird und du anfängst dich entsprechend zu verhalten. Aber die Grundlage hast du ja dann schon durch viele tausend Stunden Fußball gelegt, bis dann endgültig dann dieser Traum dann da ist und aus dem Traum dann eben mehr wird.
Aber waren das dann auch so Fußballbiografien, an denen sie sich dann später orientiert haben? Der Unterschied ist ja auch so ein bisschen, diejenigen haben in ihrer Jugend noch eben im Nachkriegsdeutschland gespielt und sie sind ja dann schon in der Zeit aufgewachsen, die man als Wirtschaftswunder bezeichnet, also wo es zumindest für viele Haushalte in Deutschland dann auch finanziell etwas bergauf ging.
Ja, ich habe mich auch sehr gewundert. Ich habe es ja in meinem Buch beschrieben. Also es war eben schon so, dass wir mit vier Kindern in einer ganz engen Wohnung gelebt haben. Dass die Toilette draußen auf dem Gang war, dass du, wenn du auf die Toilette wolltest, erst mal dich aus der Wohnung raus musstest. Dann den Knopf, der hat dann vielleicht so 30 Sekunden gehalten. In der Zeit musstest du alles erledigen, sonst musstest du im Dunkeln zurück. Wir haben in einer Zinkbadewanne gebadet. Wir waren vier Kinder und Vater auch noch nach Beruf. Von daher war das jetzt im Nachhinein nicht unbedingt vom Status her, vom Finanziellen her, für meine Familie jetzt eine herausragende Nackkriegszeit, aber ich habe nie was vermisst. Aus dem einfachen Grunde war immer genug zu essen und zu trinken da. Also die Grundbedürfnisse, Dach über dem Kopf, Kleidung, Kühlschrank voll, die wurden schon befriedigt. Und alles andere, weil ich kannte es auch nicht anders und deswegen habe ich auch nichts vermisst. Und alles andere habe ich erst kennengelernt, aus einem höheren Wohlstand mit unserem Umzug nach Westerkappeln und mit der Beförderung meines Vaters eben zum Bezirksschornsteinfeger Meister war er dann im Grunde genommen Unternehmer. Erst da hat sich dann für uns was verändert. Die Wohnung war größer, dann auf einmal nur noch zwei Kinder in einem Zimmer. Es gab jeden Tag Milch vom Milchmann, es gab jeden Tag Eier vom Eiermann, der klingelte und vorbeikam. Also erst ab neuter Lebensjahr, also von mir, so um 1966 ist uns das dann bewusster geworden. Und was wir vorher nicht hatten, das war aber auch kein Problem, das nicht zu haben, denn das hat auch den Hunger so ein bisschen vielleicht verstärkt, andere Dinge im Leben dann anzustreben und zu erreichen.
Und dann, sie haben es ja vorhin schon gesagt, ab neun Jahren waren sie dann auch erst in einem Fußballverein, dann wurden sie quasi von der Straße auf einem Feld, war es wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich Ascheplatz?
Nein, wir hatten damals da ausschließlich einen Rasenplatz.
Ui, das war aber dann wahrscheinlich schon ein Platz.
Nur ein für alle Mannschaften. Das bedeutete dann im Winter eben für alle Mannschaften auch in einer sehr, sehr kleinen Turnhalle zu trainieren. Drei gegen drei, vier gegen vier, da hatten wir den Straßenfußballer noch wieder. Nee, es war ein Rasenplatz.
Nicht schlecht. Sie schreiben in ihrem Buch doch relativ ausführlich über diese Zeit und auch über einen Aspekt im Verhältnis zu ihrem Vater, der dem Alkohol sehr zugetan war und das immer wieder zu Konflikten geführt hat. Nicht zu Gewalt im Haushalt, aber zu Situationen, die heute noch manchmal in ihrem Leben eine Rolle spielen und zwar auch in ihrem Trainerberuf. Können Sie kurz noch mal erklären, wie das zustande ist?
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie sich das vorstellen können. Da kann man sich auch nicht reinversetzen. Zunächst mal, wenn ein Elternteil dem Alkohol verfallen ist. Das ist ja eine schwere Krankheit, was dir als Kind aber nicht bewusst ist. Denn dann hat das schon einen schweren, schweren Einfluss auch auf deine Entwicklung, auf dein Selbstwertgefühl, wo man im Leben ja daran arbeiten kann. Aber in dem Alter ist das alles andere als einfach. Und das Verständnis dafür, das hast du in dem Moment nicht. Das entwickelt sich dann später, wenn erst vielleicht sogar nach dem Ableben. Da war ich 19. Da muss aber auch die Vorgeschichte sein, dass mein Vater in dieser Zeit groß geworden ist, dass er fast noch in den Krieg reingerutscht wäre, dass er ein uneheliches Kind war, seinen Vater nie kennengelernt hat. Eine sehr, sehr gute Mutter hatte meine Oma Ida. Aber dass du damals, in der Nachkriegszeit, das war schon ein riesen Problem, wenn du unehelich warst. Und dass du dann in der Zeit, da ging es nur um Grundbedürfnisse, dass du dann nicht mit allzu viel Liebe groß wirst. Und dass dann, obwohl du es in dir hast, nicht weitergeben kannst. Also wir Kinder wussten immer, der ist gut. Das ist ein sehr guter Kerl, das ist ein sehr guter Mensch. Der kann das aber dann nicht so rüberbringen, der kann es nicht so zeigen. Und seine kranke Seele, Alkoholiker haben immer eine kranke Seele, hat er dann eben im Alkohol erdrängt. Und das ist für Kinder alles andere als einfach, weil du siehst Dinge und erlebst Dinge, die du anderen Menschen eben nicht wünscht. Und die dich selber auch prägen. Später aber erst, was nimmst du da mit? Nur das Selbstgefühl leidet natürlich extrem darunter. Du musst dann im Leben dich schon sehr stark reflektieren, um entsprechende Entwicklungsschritte machen zu können. Aber es geht. Und im Nachhinein, um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, wenn du dann irgendwann damit abschließt – und für mich war das Buch auch, das war mir aber erst mit dem Abschluss bewusst. Weil während des Schreibens, mit dem Kai Psotter zusammen und meiner Frau, bin ich nochmal sehr krank geworden, weil vieles nochmal hochgekommen ist und aufgewühlt wurde. Und dann empfindest du die Dinge nochmal durch, was man ja eigentlich nicht will. Aber durch das Abschließen des Buchs, durch das Fertigstellen, wie es dann geschrieben war, war es fast wie auf einem Schlag, ging es mir deutlich besser. Und für mich war das so ein bisschen, ohne dass ich meine Vergangenheit leuchne – ich stehe dazu – auch zu allen Menschen, mit denen ich früher zu tun hatte. Was ich damit meine ist, konnte ich meine persönliche Geschichte aufgeben und hinter mir lassen. Viele Dinge dadurch erst sehr spät verarbeitet haben. Ist mir aber dann erst mit Abschluss des Buches dann sehr bewusst geworden, was da noch aufzuarbeiten war, wie vieles noch versteckt war und wie viel es mich noch belastet hat. Also heute – das merken Sie ja auch jetzt, das könnte ich auch öffentlich – ist es in dem Moment, wo ich darüber spreche, keine Belastung mehr für mich. Und so hat es mir geholfen. Ich glaube auch, dass es aber auch anderen Menschen helfen kann. Denn es gibt Menschen, denen ist es in ihrem Leben deutlich schlechter gegangen als mir. Und die mussten vielleicht unter ganz anderen Dingen leiden. Und so glaube ich einfach. Und irgendwie muss man sich diesen Titel, gib alles nur nie auf, ja auch, verdient und erarbeitet haben. Da muss es ja Gründe geben, dass man sich überhaupt traut, den zu nutzen. Und da gehört meine Geschichte natürlich ein bisschen dazu.
Und sie bringen es eben in Verbindung mit Situationen heute noch, wenn sie als Trainer an der Seitenlinie stehen und das Gefühl haben, sie können keinen Einfluss mehr auf ihre Mannschaft nehmen. In dieser Sekunde diese Machtlosigkeit, die sie eben damals auch empfunden haben, zum Teil gegenüber ihrem Vater. Und das fand ich eben interessant, weil das ja völlig, also es ist nachvollziehbar, auch wenn es eigentlich unmöglich ist, in so etwas hinein zu versetzen, aber man kann es quasi logisch nachvollziehen. Und ich finde das so interessant, weil das dann ja etwas ist, was noch für ihre Arbeit immer noch eine solche Bedeutung hat und aber so tief in ihrer Biografie verankert ist. Und weil es in ihrem Job ja auch viel darum geht, Spieler zu verstehen, als Mensch zu verstehen und nicht nur als Spieler, habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, wie sehr kann man den Menschen eigentlich von seiner Biografie trennen? Müsste man jetzt nicht eigentlich mit jedem Spieler auch zum Teil bis ins Detail gehen, um so manche Dinge nachvollziehen zu können?
Es ist wichtig, dass du deine Spieler verstehst, dass du Einfüllungsvermögen hast, dass du empathisch bist, sonst kannst du ihnen nicht helfen. Und sonst vertrauen sie dir auch nicht. Es ist wichtig, dass dir deine Spieler vertrauen. Und jeder gute Trainer sollte auch psychologisch geschult sein, sollte zumindest ein sehr guter Hobbypsychologe sein. Aber wir sind sicherlich nicht dafür da. Das kann punktuell mal der Fall sein, dass wir tiefenpsychologisch werden. Es ist aber wichtig, sich mit diesen Dingen zu befassen.
Es ist auch eine Verantwortung.
Ja, wir haben eine Riesenverantwortung. Es ist wichtig zu wissen für uns auch, dass – früher gab es ja mal Kassetten, CDs, heute nimmt man die Dinge anders auf, aber ich versuche es mal über die Schiene zu erklären – dass wenn wir geboren werden als Mensch, dann werden wir mit einer unbespielten CD oder Kassette zur Welt kommen. Also im Grunde genommen hieß das früher mal Unrecorded und alles, was wir in unserem Leben gesehen, gehört, gefühlt haben, ist auf dieser Kassette gespeichert und da sind vor allen Dingen die ersten sechs Lebensjahre ganz entscheidend. Diese Programmierung steuert natürlich auch unser Verhalten. Deswegen ist es wichtig – ich finde es schon wichtig, dass ein Trainer sich mit solchen Dingen befassen muss, um gegebenenfalls und situativ immer wieder in der Lage zu sein, auch seinen Spielern Hilfestellung zu geben, Unterstützung zu geben. Denn solange der Mensch lebt – der Überzeugung bin ich – sind Körper und Seele eine Einheit. Und das bedeutet eben, dass jeder eine Seele hat. Und auch jeder, der da in der Arena spielt, hat eine Seele. Und das ist schon wichtig als Trainer zu wissen und zu fühlen, mit wem habe ich es da zu tun. Und wenn die Spieler möchten, dann sollten sie auch das Gefühl haben, dem kannst du vertrauen. Dem Coach kannst du vertrauen. Der hört dir zu, der gibt das nicht weiter. Und der ist gegebenenfalls in der Lage, dir vielleicht auch mal über das Zuhören hinaus auch mal einen guten Tipp zu geben.
Welchen Tipp hätten sie denn ihrem 17-jährigen Ich gegeben, als es dann langsam richtig ans wurde, auch mit dem Profifußball? Sie wären ja sogar fast zum FC Bayern München gewechselt. Sie haben es ja Sepp Maier und der Revolte zu verdanken, dass Max Merkel damals nicht zu Bayern als Trainer kam. Der hätte sie wahrscheinlich mitgenommen.
Das war damals so. Das hätte gut passieren können, wobei mir das andersherum lieber war, hier in meiner Heimat spielen zu können bei meinem Lieblingsverein von Geburt an. Welchen Tipp ich mir damals gegeben hätte, kann ich so ad hoc nicht beantworten? Vielleicht helfen sie mir auch mal auf die Sprache.
Das ist eine Antwort, die können nur sie beantworten. Aber wir können uns ja auf anderen Ebenen dieser Antwort noch anlehnen. Denken sie noch manchmal drüber nach? Ich habe jetzt eine Idee.
Ich hätte mir als erstes gesagt, sei jeden Tag der Beste, der du sein kannst. Das heißt, gib jeden Tag dein Bestes. Dann hätte ich mir gesagt, auch gerade als Profifußballer, verliere nie den Spaß daran. Der Spaß muss immer größer sein als der individuelle Druck, den jeder ja nur anders empfindet. Ich hätte dann auch gesagt, Fußball ist eine Wir-Sport. Das heißt nicht, dass ich damals ein egoistischer Spieler war, aber schon eben dadurch, dass ich nicht ein Dribbler war, auch sehr viel alleine gemacht habe. Ich bin schon in einer Zeit damals groß geworden, wenn ich Profifußball so empfunden habe, dass es miteinander nicht so stark ausgeprägt war, wie es eigentlich sein sollte. Und dann hätte ich mir diesen Tipp vorher gegeben, du we first.
Das finde ich ganz interessant, weil wenn man sich auf ihre Profi-Laufbahn konzentriert und das auch in ihrem Buch nochmal sehr detailliert nachlesen kann, dann gibt es ja auch immer wieder die Momente, wo sie in der Rückschau sagen, da hätte ich vielleicht auch mal selbstbewusster auftreten sollen innerhalb der Mannschaft. Genauso wie es die Momente gibt, wie sie dann auch manchmal schreiben, da hätte ich mich dann vielleicht auch zurücknehmen müssen in meinem Verhalten. Ja, ehrlich gesagt, liest man da schon manchmal den Trainer, der jetzt auf einen Spieler blickt, heraus. Das fand ich auch so in der Metaperspektive ganz spannend. Aber erzählen Sie mir doch nochmal, wie war denn das damals mit Max Merkel, dann auf Schalke und dann im Profisport anzukommen? Wie groß war damals der Sprung von dem, was sie bei sich im Verein erlebt hatten, zu dem, was sie dann auf Schalke erlebt haben?
Ja, der Straßenfußball hatte mich schon geprägt, also mich auch durchsetzen zu können und zu müssen und zu behaupten und da ging es dann schon sehr rau zur Sache. Da wurde man schon sehr gut auf das Spätere vorbereitet. Dann bei einem kleineren Verein mit einem sehr, sehr guten Trainer damals und mit vielen, vielen guten Fußballern. Ich weiß nicht, ob das damals zufällig war in so einem kleinen Ort, viele Fußballer, aber es war natürlich deutlich behüteter. Es war harmonischer. Es ging nicht so zur Sache wie in der Stadt Gelsenkirchen. Es ist jetzt überhaupt keine Wertung oder so. Ich bin dann eben nicht mit den Abi Abramschiks groß geworden, die sich hier im Podcast durchsetzen mussten und eben mit vielen gleichwertigen Spielern oder Besseren groß geworden, sondern da im kleinen Westakappeln hatten wir viele hervorragende Fußballspieler. Da warst du dann schon doch ein bisschen herausragend. Von daher hatte ich im Straßenfußball kämpfen gelernt, aber war dieses sich durchsetzen in einem so starken Kader natürlich in keinster Weise gewohnt, weil ich da in der Mannschaft damals gesetzt war. Und das war ich dann natürlich, als ich mit 18 anfing, definitiv nicht, auch wenn ich meine Spielanteile hatte, aufgrund dessen, dass ich ganz ordentlich Fußball spielen konnte.
Und dann kommt ja noch ein gesundheitlicher Aspekt mit in Ihre Biografie mit dazu. Also nach nur drei Spielen für Schalke konnten sie dann auf einmal im Training nicht mehr mithalten, obwohl sie eigentlich ein relativ fitter Spieler waren. Und als sie dann der Trainer Merkel im Kapital von Karl Marx hat Blättern sehen, dann war es dann endgültig soweit. Sie mussten wechseln, so waren die Zeiten damals. Sie sind dann zu Westfalia Herne gegangen und anschließend wurde dann bei ihnen eine Nierenkrankheit diagnostiziert, bei der sie um ein Haar tatsächlich auch eine Niere verloren hätten. Also eine sehr ernsthafte Krankheit. Warum ist denn das vorher? Mannschaftsarzt etc. nicht aufgefallen?
Ja, du wirst ja, du wirst zwar durchgecheckt, aber das ist ganz normal. Die ganz normalen Parameter werden da gemessen. Unter anderem wird auch ein Leistungs-EKG gemacht und mit dem Herzen war alles in Ordnung. Also ich weiß nicht, inwieweit du heute geröntet oder oder in ein MRT musst, um sich die Organe anzuschauen. Hat man damals nicht gemacht, hat man heute nicht gemacht. Und es gab ja für die Ärzte bis dahin auch keine Anzeichen dafür. Ich hatte zwar immer mal wieder Beschwerden hier im Bereich, das haben wir Eltern und ich, dann haben wir irgendwie abgetan mit irgendwas Magen oder irgendwas anderes und sind da sicherlich gemeinsam zu oberflächlich mit umgegangen. Aber so ganz große Anzeichen gab es bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht. Aber man hat hinterher festgestellt, dass Ome das jetzt zu sehr zu vertiefen, dass es schon ein Geburtsfehler war. Geburtsfehler, aus welchen Gründen könnte man jetzt mutmaßen, will ich aber nicht, weil das ist auch vorbei. Wer oder was hat da Schuld oder so, das zählt ja nicht, weil auch das gehört zu meinem Leben, dazu möchte ich auch nicht missen. Es hätte einfacher sein können durch eine bessere Gesundheit, aber die Dinge haben ich natürlich auch zu dem gemacht, der ich heute bin, haben auch ihren Beitrag dazu geleistet. Und es war damals eben so, dass durch dieses Ewige, durch das Schlappe dann und nicht mehr so mithalten können, dass irgendwann dann eben zu einer Untersuchung kam. Und da war der selbst der Hausarzt damals sehr geschockt.
Eine Niere so groß wie ein Fußball, schreiben sie es in ihrem Buch.
Ja, das ist der beste Vergleich. Aber der Niere ist eigentlich relativ klein, die war damals schon riesig. Muss man sich so vorstellen, dass rings um die Niere durch die durch die Jahre so viel totes Gewebe war. Und wenn das rings um die Niere geht, dann geht das schon fast in diese Größe rein. Und das hat dann oft schon auch mal gedrückt. Und ich habe auch öfter mal das Schmerzen gehabt, aber wahrscheinlich ist noch mal keiner in meiner Umgebung und ich selber nicht so ernst genommen. Und das verstärkte sich dann aber zu den konditionellen Schwierigkeiten.
Also das führte dann zu einer dramatischen Operation. Es war nicht klar, ob sie ihre Niere würden behalten können. Und anschließend hat es dann vor allem dazu geführt, also da gehören noch viele, viele Ereignisse dazu. Das kann man ja auch alles im Buch ganz gut nachlesen. Aber es hat dann dazu geführt, die Niere konnte erhalten werden. Sie haben auch diese Operation überstanden. Irgendwann durch einen kleinen Krankenhausausflug, würde ich mal sagen, sind dann auch die Wunden verheilt. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht näher drauf eingehen. Aber dann begann ja für sie der lange Weg wieder zurück um den Fußball. Und da habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, also sie haben alles dafür gegeben, um wieder in den Profifußball zu kommen. Es ist ihnen dann auch gelungen. Warum wollten sie das eigentlich so sehr?
Welche Alternativen hatte ich? Also das habe ich von der Pika auf gelernt und war definitiv. Trotz Handicaps gut. Obwohl ich auch mit 16 schon Jugendmannschaften trainiert habe, das kam mir dann später noch als Vorteil dazu. Das Ganze war ja nicht vollendet. Ich hatte schon Alternativen. Ich glaube, ich wäre bei aller Bescheidenheit ein ziemlich guter Lehrer oder Ausbilder, auch in anderen Branchen geworden. Das lag mir schon immer. Meine Frau sagt ja immer, im Coaching sehe ich dich noch besser als früher als Spieler, obwohl ich ein ganz guter Spieler war. Aber es war eben unvollendet und es war eben Abbruch nach so kurzer Zeit, obwohl es ein guter Start war. Ich hatte in den ersten drei Spielen als 18-Jähriger meine Spielanteile gehabt. Ich habe eben neidenschaftlich gerne Fußball gespielt und wollte es dann einfach noch mal wissen. Einmal, weil ich das am liebsten gemacht habe und ganz gut konnte und dann auch damals mangels Alternativen. Ich hatte ja mittelreife aufgehört, also ich war zunächst mal auf dem Gymnasium. Das hat auch bis zur dritten Klasse gereicht, ohne Schularbeiten. Und dann hatte ich mittelreife gemacht, eine kurze Lehre angefangen bei meinem Vater, die aber dann irgendwann aus bestimmten Gründen auch beendet hat, auch mit Fußball zu tun. Ja, sodass es so viele Möglichkeiten nicht gab. Ich hätte im Grunde genommen ganz von vorne anfangen müssen nochmal. Ich hätte das Abi nachholen müssen, weil dann wäre es nämlich in Richtung Pädagogik, wäre es in Richtung Lehrer gegangen. Nochmal ein Studium vor mir gehabt und das waren so die Gründe. Und ja, ich hatte glaube ich auch eine ziemliche Kraft und Energie, dann aber auch Unterstützung durch meine Frau, um das damals scheinbar unmögliche dann möglich zu machen, weil die Ärzte hatten damals doch sehr von abgeraten.
Und sie haben es eben geschafft. Sie haben es auch sogar nochmal zurück zu Schalke geschafft. Wenn sie an ihre Profizeit denken, die dann nach siebeneinhalb Jahren ja dann auch dann schon relativ früh vorbei war, auch aufgrund eben dieser gesundheitlichen Dinge. Woran denken sie, wenn sie an ihre Profizeit denken? Denken sie an die Zeit vor dieser Nieren-OP? Denken sie an die Zeit danach? Denken sie daran, was hätte sein können, wenn man das früher entdeckt hätte?
Zunächst denke ich an die positiven Erlebnisse. Einmal das Comeback geschafft zu haben oder sagen wir an das erste Bundesligaspiel mit mit 18 in Hamburg. Das sind schon schon sehr besondere Erlebnisse und auch Glücksmomente, dann das Comeback geschafft zu haben. Dann hier gegen Bayern war, glaube ich, mein erstes Spiel wieder hier mit 21 nach dem Comeback. Dann wirst du eingewechselt und dann steht am nächsten Tag in der Zeitung der Mann mit den 1000 Tricks und ähnliche Dinge oder wieder da oder an die ersten Tore in der Bundesliga. Das sind Dinge, die haben sich schon sehr stark bei mir eingraviert. Also das Positive ist da deutlich im Vordergrund. Ich weiß sehr wohl, dass bei optimaler Gesundheit ich eine ganz andere Karriere vor mir gehabt hätte, weil das wäre alles viel einfacher gewesen. Gerade das körperliche Training war danach für mich kein Kinderspiel. Mit der einen oder anderen, nicht nur mit der Vorschädigung, Hochleistungssport zu betreiben, war ja nicht einfach. Ich hatte ja nach der OP, selbst in meinem ersten Profijahr, immer noch Blutimmurin. Das heißt, da, wo man normalerweise gelb pinkelt, kam bei mir rotes raus. Das kann man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen. Das hat die Dinge sicherlich nicht vereinbart. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das damals ging. Heute erschreckt man sich zu Tode und als junger Mensch wird schon wieder weggehen. Das spricht mit den Ärzten, die sagen, das ist totes Gewebe, was nachblutet, da drin kommt keine Luft dran. Das war alles andere als einfach. Ich sage jetzt zwar, ich bin kein Konjunktiv, Epigon oder so, das hilft dir ja nicht weiter. Für die Voraussetzungen, mit denen ich auf die Welt kam, da waren ja noch andere Dinge, ist mein Leben verdammt gut gelaufen und auch diese Situation. Von daher blicke ich da eher positiv zurück, wohl wissend, dass bei aller Demut es wahrscheinlich zum Nationalspieler gereicht hätte bei vollständiger Gesundheit, weil ich war technisch ein ganz guter Fußballer und das glaube ich schon, dass das dann so weit gekommen wäre. Aber was wäre dann anders? Wir leben ja im Hier und Jetzt. Unsere vergangenheitliche Geschichte gehört dazu, aber vor allen Dingen leben wir jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt und in der Zukunft, wenn alles gut läuft.
Es gehört ja auch insofern mit dazu, dass Sie ja schon beschrieben haben, dass dann auch die Aufarbeitung im Buch ja auch nochmal für Sie jetzt etwas bedeutet hat, jetzt so, wie Sie hier sitzen und Sie haben auch in einem Interview gesagt, es sei Ihnen schwergefallen von der Alkoholkrankheit Ihres Vaters oder auch Ihrer Krankheit zu sprechen. Wie viel davon haben Sie denn jetzt im Verlauf Ihrer Trainerkarriere mit Ihren Spielern geteilt? Wie viel wissen die von Ihnen?
Ich spreche ganz selten über mich, weil es ist ein Spielerspiel und kein Trainerspiel, weil wir Trainer gehören dazu. Ich bin kein Trainer, der aus seiner Vergangenheit lebt. Die Spiele überzeugen, was ich früher mal für ein toller Hecht war. So versuche ich nicht, auf meine Spieler zuzugehen, sondern ich versuche sie mit dem, was ich heute kann und weiß, zu überzeugen. Aber es gibt sicherlich Situationen, kommt aber selten vor, wo ich ihnen schon mal sage, meine Güte, ihr seid kerngesund, ihr habt eine unfassbare Lebenschance, schaut euch das Ding hier, schaut euch das mal an, dann erzähle ich kurz darüber, was trotzdem möglich ist und was ist alles möglich für euch, wenn ihr, wenn ihr je hinter euer Bestes gebt, wenn ihr eure Einstellung nochmal einen Ticken nach oben schraubt und so weiter über die Alkoholgeschichte meines Vaters nicht. Also wenn ich mit unseren Jungs spreche und sie vertrauen mir dann Dinge, persönliche Dinge an, dann sag ich schon mal, du meine Kindheit war definitiv auch alles andere als einfach und nur mach jetzt das Beste daraus und bleib da nicht drin hängen, weil letztendlich, es gibt Ausnahmen, wenn ich in Afrika groß werde mit null Chance, hab von der Geburt an schon AIDS, dann kann ich nicht von Chancengleichheit sprechen. Wenn ich irgendwo in den Slums groß werde, dann kann ich nicht sagen, der hat die gleichen Chancen wie ich. Aber wenn ich hier groß werde, einigermaßen vernünftig groß werde, dann, und es hat aber Schwierigkeiten in der Kindheit gegeben, es gibt Schwierigkeiten im Leben, dann ist das so, dann darfst du aber nicht irgendwelchen Personen deines Lebens permanent für deinen Versagen oder dafür, dass es bei dir in deinem Leben nicht läuft, die Schuld geben. Denn dann kannst du sagen, mein Opa, Oma oder irgendjemand aus dem Leben war schuld, weil ich irgendwann mal eine geknallt gekriegt habe. Das ist alles nicht schön. Naja, aber wichtig ist, und das versuche ich den Jungs immer wieder zu vermitteln, in den Spiegel zu schauen, denn da ist der Mensch, der dafür verantwortlich ist. Zumindest dann ab jetzt, ob du erfolgreich bist, wirst oder nicht.
Und ab wann hatten sie diese Einstellung und woher haben sie die bekommen?
Die Frage ist gut. Also ich hatte ja in meiner Kindheit nicht allzu viele Mentoren. Ich hatte einen Jugendtrainer, der kommt in dem Buch auch vor, ich hatte mehrere gute Jugendtrainer auch, aber einer, der mich besonders geprägt hat, der mich in der Jugend trainiert hat, als Senior dann auch trainiert hat, der Lothar Ratzlaff damals aus Westerkappeln, der hat mich sehr geprägt. Aber damals gab es auch nicht so dieses Mentoring wie heute, direkte Vorbilder. Schwierig, also was ich immer schon getan habe, später dann, ein, zwei Jahre später dann, ab dann schon mit meiner Frau, sehr viel gelesen. Und dann bin ich sehr schnell auf Bücher zum Beispiel von Norman Vincent Peale, einer der größten Positivdenker aller Zeiten, Dale Carnegie und so weiter gestoßen. Das war dann aber zum nächsten Mal ein Lesen. Ein Lesen. Und einer meiner großen Mentoren hat mal gesagt, du kannst dein Unterbewusstsein nicht belesen. Du kannst es nur im Grunde genommen besprechen. Aber das hat dann schon so ein bisschen geholfen. Da ging es dann so ein bisschen in die Richtung. Aber du kommst nicht so schnell aus deiner Haut, aus deiner Programmierung heraus. Und aufgrund meiner Historie – keine Schuldzuweisung, betone ich immer wieder – kein Nachkarten war ich zunächst mal – oder bin es eigentlich immer noch, glaubt mir heute keiner mehr – ein sehr introvertierter Mensch, sehr in sich gekehrter Mensch, der aber irgendwas in sich hatte, was ich selbst nicht beschreiben kann. Trotz dieser Introvertie hat er schon einen großen Ehrgeiz und einen sehr starken Willen, aus dem Leben was zu machen.
Eine Kraft, die sie antreibt?
Ja, eine große Energie, eine große Kraft. Ich bin auch ein sehr gläubiger Mensch. Und später dann auch gemeinsam mit meiner Frau dann sind wir, ohne die das dann auch nicht möglich gewesen wäre, sind wir dann eben einen entsprechenden Weg gegangen und sind dann später natürlich auch auf Menschen gestoßen, die uns dann weitergeholfen haben.
Jetzt haben wir quasi dieses eine Kapitel Ihres Lebens. Ich bin jetzt einfach mal so und unterteile Ihr Leben in Kapitel, aber haben Sie ja ein Buch auch gemacht. Das eine Kapitel machen wir die Überschrift Es hätte zum Nationalspieler gereicht. Jetzt haben wir ja das zweite große Kapitel, das etwas längere Kapitel, nämlich Ihre Trainerkarriere. Wie ist es denn dann dazu gekommen, dass Sie Trainer geworden sind? Sie haben vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet, dass Sie schon sehr früh da mal reingeschnuppert haben.
Ja, ich habe schon in Westerkappeln mit 16 Jahren E- und D-Jugendmannschaften trainiert.
Warum? Einfach, weil es Ihnen Freude gemacht wird?
Es war wahnsinnig viel Spaß, mit den Kindern zu trainieren, Fußball zu spielen, etwas von dem, was ich wusste, zu vermitteln. Das hat mir damals schon sehr viel Freude gemacht. Ich habe dann auch schon gespürt, dass mir das liegt, ohne dass da schon die Idee entstand, später mal Trainer zu werden. Aber das waren sicherlich meine Anfänge als Coach. Ich habe mich auch schon immer für Dinge interessiert, wie Trainingslehre, wie den Aufbau einer Trainingseinheit. Dann bin ich das erste Mal, als ich mit 27, 5 aufhörte, nach diesen sieben und einhalb Jahren nochmal, nein, nach diesen viereinhalb Jahren, nein, sieben und einhalb Jahren, habe ich dann auch das erste Mal eine Seniorenmannschaft trainiert, in unserer Wahlheimat Schermbeck damals. Und ich habe dann auch gemerkt, dass mir das liegt, auch mit Senioren. Ob Kreisliga oder Bundesliga, du hast immer mit Menschen zu tun. Und du hast immer zu führen. Das eine ist nicht unbedingt einfacher als das andere. Dann haben wir uns selbstständig gemacht, meine Frau und ich mit Partner und Frau damals in der Fitnessbranche. Wir haben ein großes Fitnessstudio aufgemacht mit Squash. Damals hatte ich dann auch die Lizenzen für den Fitnessbereich gemacht. In Kürzester Zeit habe ich den Squash-Trainer in einer eigenen Anlage gemacht. Auch das lag mir ganz gut, mit Individualsportlern zu trainieren. Das hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht, mich geformt und mich weitergebracht. Davon profitiere ich sicherlich heute noch auch als Fußballtrainer, weil ich den athletischen Teil selber abdecken kann. Ich habe jede Menge Erfahrung gesammelt, auch in anderen Bereichen. Coach ist Coach, Trainer ist Trainer. Ich hatte damals zwei Hunde, die meine Frau Conny zur Ausstellung mitgenommen hat. Ich habe Hunde ausgebildet. Wenn meine Jungs das hören, dann sagen sie schon mal, dass ich Schmunzeln dabei habe. Irgendetwas hatte immer schon mit Coaching zu tun. Als wir damals geschäftlich auseinandergingen, ich habe es auch ein bisschen im Buch beschrieben, wir waren gut, wir haben uns auch gut verstanden. Wir hatten auch Zulauf, aber wir hatten eben von Wirtschaftlichkeit und von viel Jahresplan, du musst so ein Unternehmen ja über 15 Jahre planen. Da hatten wir wenig Ahnung und dann kam irgendwann unser Steuerbehalter und überblickte unsere Finanzen und sagte, das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Das geht nur noch für eine Partei. Und unser damaliger Partner hat dann gesagt, er würde das unheimlich gerne weitermachen mit allen Schulden, mit allem Drum und Dran und hat es dann ja später auch wirklich extrem weit gebracht. Und unsere Alternative war dann zunächst mal zurück in den Fußball. Und dass meine Frau dann eben auch, die ja im Geschäft immer mitgearbeitet hatte, dann eben auch wieder zurück in den alten Beruf bzw. dann irgendwann auch mal in der Medizintechnik eine Abteilung geleitet hat. Sodass wir dann schon über ganz, ganz viele Jahre extrem kämpfen mussten, um uns finanziell zu erholen, sehr, sehr lange. Haben aber auch daraus wieder sehr viel gelernt. Und dann ging es eben zurück, Fußball. Erst im Amateurbereich und dann relativ schnell kam dann Gott sei Dank damals Schalke 04 auf mich zu, was die Person betrifft, Rudi Assau damals oder der damalige Abteilungsleiter Bodo Menze. Die zwei kamen dann auf mich zu, ob ich mir das vorstellen könnte. Und das war für uns natürlich damals schon, ja so war es geplant, aber war dann schon mindestens ein Sechser im Lotto dann auch. Das hat sich dann aber für beide Seiten dann als der Fall erwiesen.
Im Nachhinein, in der Retro-Perspektive auf jeden Fall. Ja und da Rudi Assau, da hatten sie ja sogar noch drei Spiele gemacht. Da war er Trainer, also sie kannten sich schon länger. Sie beschreiben auch in ihrem Buch, dass sie dann ein Praktikum gemacht haben bei Schalke 04 noch unter Peter Neurohrer. Und sie hatten dann, meinem Verständnis nach, sehr früh, also wir befinden uns jetzt Anfang der 90er noch, da waren sie dem Profifußball schon wieder nahe, aber sie waren noch tätig bei kleineren Vereinen. Also Schermberg haben sie schon genannt, Dinslaken, dann die U19 von Wattenscheid.
War dann aber schon wieder der semi-professionelle Bereich.
Genau, das ist dann schon der Übergang. Wie hat sich denn der Fußball verändert gehabt zu der Zeit, in der sie noch aktiv waren, bis jetzt, wo wir uns befinden, Mitte der 90er?
Boah, da hat sich schon verdammt viel getan. Zunächst mal ist sicherlich festzustellen, dass die Technik damals – vielleicht kommen wir gleich noch mal darauf zurück – mindestens genauso gut war wie heute, wenn nicht sogar besser, was die Ballbeherrschung betrifft. Der Ball ist ja das Spielobjekt, und das Spielobjekt gilt es natürlich in erster Linie zu beherrschen. Wenn du den Ball nicht beherrschst, beherrscht er dich, dominiert er dich. Das ist schon mal Grundvoraussetzung. Das Spiel an sich hat sich natürlich schon gewaltig verändert. Zu meiner Zeit war uns damals aber nicht so bewusst. Es war mehr eine Ausdauersportart. Es ist viel gelaufen worden, aber eben nicht so viel gesprintet worden wie heute. Heute kommt es ja vor allen Dingen auf die gesprinteten Meter im hochintensiven Bereich an. Das war damals so nicht der Fall. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir nicht gesprintet sind. Es ist auch schon ganz schön viel gelaufen worden, aber eben nicht so ökonomisch und häufig auch unnötig, weil damals gab es noch die Mann-Dekung. Das heißt, jeder hatte seinen Gegenspieler, und den hatte er über den ganzen Platz zu verfolgen. Also Ernst Tappel hat ja mal in seiner Zeit, als er in Hamburg war, gesagt, Eselsfußball, dem kann ich zustimmen. Also für mich war das ein Albtraum, im Mittelfeld zu spielen. Du bist auf der rechten Seite, ziehst einen Sprint dann auf die linke Seite, und dein Mann geht jetzt nicht mit.
Ja, dann musst du wieder zurück.
Du sprintest 80 Meter, und die anderen haben den Ball. Wo ist der? Und dann lässt er dich kommen, lässt er dich erst mal dahinsprinten. Sobald du bei ihm bist, macht er natürlich dann nochmal einen Sprint. Es war damals ein ganz anderer Fußball. Der Fußball hat sich in den letzten 20, 25 Jahren vor allen Dingen taktisch und vom Tempo her sehr stark weiterentwickelt. Es sind ja nur, was Ballorientiertheit betrifft, was Pressing betrifft, was Verschieben betrifft. Das gab es ja damals in der Form noch nicht so. Das heißt nicht, dass wir damals dumme Fußballer waren. Aber dass der Fußball in Deutschland noch nicht so weit war. Es gab es ja schon in Skandinavien, es gab es ja schon in Russland damals noch, Sowjetunion, Valeriy Lobanovski, Dynamo Kiev. Und es gab auch schon den totalen Fußball in Holland. Aber wir Deutschen waren damals, wir meinten, gut genug zu sein, dass wir mit unseren Tugenden und mit diesen vielen herausragenden Einzelspielern, dass das immer reichen würde. Es hat sich dann irgendwann dabei erwiesen, dass das nicht der Fall war.
Genau, Italien kann man wahrscheinlich auch noch nennen mit Saki.
Vor allen Dingen defensiv, ja genau. Defensive, aber später Saki natürlich auch, oder auch Milan, was Pressing betrifft und was andere Dinge betrifft.
Wie haben Sie sich dann taktisch weitergebildet? Denn wenn man jetzt in der Retrospektive auf vor allem die Mitte der 90er guckt, dann ist das so ein bisschen, als würde man in eine Wüste gucken aus taktischer Sicht, wenn man sich den deutschen Fußball anguckt. Und es gibt Oasen außen rum, die haben Sie ja gerade auch schon beschrieben. Und der deutsche Fußball musste das in seiner Gesamtheit auf die ziemlich harte Tour lernen über schlechtes Abschneiden der Vereinsmannschaften und dann vor allem auch der Nationalmannschaft, dass es da so etwas gibt wie Raumdeckung, dass Viererkette funktionieren kann, dass man kein Lieber hochraucht und so weiter und so fort. Wo haben Sie sich damals taktisch weitergebildet? Wie haben Sie das angestellt?
Ja, du hattest damals ja nicht die Möglichkeiten, sagen wir mal, spanischen, englischen Fußball, italienischen Fußball zu sehen. Aber es gab schon immer die Möglichkeit, sich Bücher zu bestellen, sich Videokassetten zu bestellen. Und da bin ich meiner Frau heute noch dankbar, obwohl wir uns finanziell wirklich nicht auf Hosen gebettet waren, dass sie dann immer gesagt haben, ja, mach mal, mach mal, mach mal. Nach dem Motto, es wird sich irgendwann lohnen, aus dir wird doch noch was, habe ich mir bergeweise Literatur gestellt, auch aus allen anderen Ländern, auch englischsprachig und und und. Habe dann immer versucht, gerade was Holland betrifft, aber auch was spanische Dinge betrifft, Brasilien. Ich habe schon eine ziemlich große Bibliothek, nicht nur aus der jüngsten Vergangenheit, auch von damals. Habe mir Trainingseinheiten von Profimannschaften angesehen und einfach alle Möglichkeiten genutzt. Damals gab es ja noch kein Internet, heute sind die Möglichkeiten ja ganz andere. Aber alle Möglichkeiten genutzt, die es gab, vor allen Dingen Bücher, DVDs, Videokassetten. Und da eben fast täglich dran gearbeitet, besser zu werden.
Würden Sie sagen, dass Sie damit in der damaligen Trainerriege ein Exot waren?
Vielleicht was meine Haarlänge betrifft. Eines mache ich nie, mich irgendwo ausschließen. Dann spreche ich über andere. Es war schon immer meine Prämisse, das weiß ich nicht, was mit anderen ist. Ich gebe immer wieder auch meinen Spielern oder auch jungen Kollegen die Empfehlung. Sei jeden Tag der Beste, der du sein kannst. Das heißt, heute besser als gestern, morgen besser als heute. Das bedeutet eben lebenslange Weiterentwicklung. Persönlich und fachlich. Und dann kommst du um solche Dinge gar nicht umhin. Weil wenn du das nicht tust, wenn du dich nicht weiterentwickelst und verbesserst, dann bleibst du stehen. Und wenn du stehen bleibst, dann wird es dich irgendwann nicht mehr geben. Also alle Lebewesen, hat schon damals Charles Darwin gesagt, die sich nicht weiterentwickelt haben, die sterben irgendwann aus. Und das ist mit uns Menschen das Gleiche. Die sterben da nicht unbedingt, aber die sind dann weg vom Fenster in ihrer Branche.
Sie haben ihr Trainingscredo im Buch auch formuliert. Also letztlich ist das gesamte Buch, bildet ihr Credo ab. Aber sie haben es an einer Stelle besonders zusammengefasst. Da schreiben sie Zitat. Für einen guten Trainer stehen seine Spieler an erster Stelle. Er sollte Empathie und emotionale Intelligenz haben. Er muss Lehrer, Pädagoge, Psychologe, Coach und Menschenführer sein. Auch sollte er mehr vermitteln als nur Technik, Taktik, Kondition und mentale Stärke. Zum Beispiel wichtige Werte wie Hilfsbereitschaft, Dankbarkeit, Demut, Ehrlichkeit und Teamfähigkeit. Wie viel von dem, was in diesem Credo steckt, wird einem denn in der Ausbildung zum Trainer vermittelt?
Ich habe noch keine Trainer-Ausbildung erlebt, die betont hat oder gesagt hat, dass Werte nicht wichtig sind. Ich glaube, das weiß jeder. Es geht nur darum, Wissen ist wenig, Können ist können. Es geht darum, Werte auch zu leben. Es wurde in meiner Ausbildung damals sicherlich auch werteorientiert ausgebildet. Aber es war kein Thema, kein extra Thema in der Ausbildung. Es wurde damals nicht betont. Das heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht gelehrt oder gelebt wurde. Aber es war schon immer der Fall. Ich finde, in der heutigen Zeit, wo wir Menschen schon riesen Probleme haben auf dem Planeten, die dürfen wir Fußballtrainer auch nicht übersehen. Weil wir so ein tolles Leben haben oder unsere Profis ein noch tolleres Leben haben, dürfen wir solche Dinge nicht übersehen. Wir neigen auf unserem Planeten immer stärker dazu, in Gegensätzen zu denken, zu schauen, was trennt uns, was unterscheidet uns, anstatt darauf zu schauen, was verbindet uns, was haben wir gemeinsam. Da ist der Fußball, finde ich, schon sehr, sehr vorbildlich für die Gesamtgesellschaft. Weil es in einer Fußballmannschaft hier bei uns keine Rolle spielt, welche Hautfarbe du hast, an welcher Religion du angehörst oder welche ethnische Herkunft du hast. Und worauf ich aber hinaus will, ist, dass gerade in dieser heutigen Hochgeschwindigkeitsteil, wo man immer mehr gegeneinander geht, wir uns nicht nur auf Technik, Taktik, Kondition, mentale Stärke, Teamgeist fokussieren kann. Ich finde, das ist ein guter Profi, dass nichts dagegen spricht, wenn das auch ein guter Mensch ist. Gerade auf den wird auch geschaut. Das sind ja häufig Vorbilder. Und wenn die das auch ein bisschen vorleben kann, dass der Gesellschaft auch wieder sehr, sehr hilft, nicht nur dem Einzelnen. Und da gehören eben so Dinge zu, gesunde Werte dazu, wie – ich spreche ja häufig, sind so meine Kernwerte. Integrität. Jetzt werden sie mich wahrscheinlich fragen, was ich meine, was das ist.
Naja, dass man aufrichtig ist.
Ja, ja, genau. Dass man im Grunde genommen, dass Worte und Taten im Einklang sind, dass man das Richtige zu tun, egal welche Konsequenzen das hat, oder egal wer dir dabei zuschaut, ohne jetzt von sich zu behaupten, ja, das ist es. Naja, aber irgendwo, irgendwo eine gewisse, ohne dass man jetzt ein moralischer Kreuzritter oder Moralapostel sein muss, finde ich es schon, HC Perkberger, über den wurde ja heute noch geschrieben, hat er damals schon gesagt, dass wir alle schon versuchen sollten, uns mindestens in den Grenzen der geltenden Moral zu bewegen. Da gehören solche Dinge eben, wie auch Integrität, wie Demut dazu. Demut ist dann eben nicht fehlender Mut, sondern nur die vollkommene Abwesenheit von Arroganz. Hilfsbereitschaft, Respekt. Jeder respektiert jeden, finde ich in der Gesellschaft ganz wichtig. Im Zusammenleben wichtig, aber auch in seiner Fußballmannschaft extrem wichtig. Dass jeder den anderen so respektiert, wie er ist, weil wir sind alles Unikate, jeder ist anders.
Und finden Sie, der Fußballwirt, da seine Vorbildfunktion, die Sie ja auch beschrieben haben, gerecht?
Teilweise schon, aber eben auch nicht permanent. Aber da können Sie mir mal ein Beispiel nennen.
Zum Beispiel ist es sehr auffällig, dass ich rund um den Rücktritt von Mesut Özil, von dem Prozedere kann man halten, was man möchte. Aber wenn ein ehemaliger Mitspieler von mir in seinem Rücktritt sich auch äußert, dass er sich manchmal diskriminiert geführt hätte aufgrund seiner Herkunft, dann hätte ich als ehemaliger Mitspieler von ihm ja auch die Möglichkeit, mich den Rücken stärkend zu äußern oder dem entgegenzuwirken und zu sagen, dass das nicht meine Überzeugung bestünde und ich entspräche. Das war zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel, wo ein Kreis von Fußballspielern auffallend ruhig war.
Ja, ich glaube, dass man sich da gegenseitig gegenseitig, ich glaube, dass gerade was Mesut betrifft, den ich als hoch anständigen Menschen kenne und schätze auch, dass aber gerade in seiner Causa eben alle Seiten und mit alle Seiten meine ich auch ihn, dass alle damals Fehler gemacht haben. Auf der anderen Seite leben wir schon in einer sehr ego-zentrierten Welt, setzt du dich durch. Ja, es gibt tatsächlich sehr, sehr viele Profis, die nur noch ihr eigenes Ego massieren. Häufig sind das aber noch keine stabilen Persönlichkeiten. Oft sind die Egos auch sehr aufgeblasen, sage ich mal, aber ohne Fundament, ohne Boden. Das sind natürlich auch alles sehr, sehr junge Menschen, die ja auch da, wo sie hingekommen sind, nicht alleine hingekommen sind. Und das vielen anderen Menschen zu verdanken haben. Es ist in dem Alter schwer, aber ich denke, die meisten entwickeln sich noch in die Richtung. Das ist eben nur, dass man nur erfolgreich wird durch andere und mit anderen. Aber da bin ich schon bei ihnen, dass im Profifußball sicherlich auch sehr stark beeinflusst durch die extrem hohen Gehälter. Damit müssen sie erst mal in dem Alter umgehen können. Das muss man erst mal einordnen können. Aber auch dadurch, dass sie natürlich sehr früh schon zu Kultfiguren, zu Stars hochgejubelt werden.
Man bewegt sich sehr früh in einem Umfeld, in dem das Umfeld zu großen Teilen sagt, du bist der Allergrößte. Und dann kommt vielleicht ein U19-Trainer und sagt, nee, Moment, in dem Bereich bist du mir noch nicht gut genug und deswegen spielst du jetzt.
Nicht vielleicht. Der kommt dann ganz bestimmt.
Ist denn dann die Menschenkenntnis das, was einen guten von einem sehr guten Trainer unterscheidet? Ihrer Meinung nach?
Ja, das wäre vielleicht zu einfach, das darauf zu reduzieren. Also ein guter Trainer, ein guter Coach braucht sicherlich vieles Fachwissen. Es ist ähnlich wie bei einem Spieler, das Talent ist eine Bedingung, ist Grundvoraussetzung und das auch dann weiterzuentwickeln und immer auf neues Zustand zu bleiben, ist eine Grundvoraussetzung. Aber die wichtigsten, du musst die Dinge auch coachen und vermitteln können, also du musst Fußball lehren können, vermitteln können. Das sind Grundvoraussetzungen, die man aber auch verbessern kann. Allerwichtigste für mich ist, dass du Menschen magst. Dass du deine Spezies sogar liebst, jetzt bitte richtig verstehen. Dass das auch die Spieler spüren, dass du dich in Menschenreihen versetzen kannst, dass du Einfühlungsvermögen, Empathie hast, dass du emotionale Intelligenz hast. Das hat auch Otto Rehagel mal zu mir gesagt. Heute finde ich es schon wichtig, dass ein Fußballtrainer intelligent ist. Da spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen. Aber mir wird das heute oft überbetont.
Die Akademisierung unserer Welt findet man auch im Fußball so ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, der EQ ist wichtig. Aber über dem EQ, emotionale Intelligenz, halte ich für deutlich wichtiger. Denn was nützt dir ein Einstein-Intelligenzquotient, wenn du mit Menschen nicht umgehen kannst oder wenn du das Maul nicht aufkommst, wenn es drauf ankommt. Diese Dinge halte ich für deutlich wichtiger.
Und wie lange brauchen Sie im Gespräch mit einem neuen Spieler, um herauszufinden, wie derjenige tickt, wenn man das überhaupt so generalisieren kann?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Es ist auch unterschiedlich, ob introvertiert oder extrovertiert. Aber ich glaube, aufgrund meiner Erfahrung und dessen, dass ich mich dann auch schon ein paar Jahrzehnte mit Menschen befasse, dass ich das relativ gut und schnell erkennen kann, ist aber unterschiedlich. Es geht nicht nur über ein Gespräch. Du musst Menschen erst mal öffnen. Das gelingt manchmal im ersten Gespräch, manchmal erst nach dem zehnten, manchmal gar nicht. Erst dann kannst du ja auch Menschen beeinflussen, wie mit einem Gefäß. Wenn ein Gefäß verschlossen ist, da kann ich nichts reingießen. Du musst Menschen erst mal öffnen, man muss erst mal Vertrauen aufbauen. Ich erwarte nicht, nur weil ich einen ganz guten Namen habe im Fußball, dass sich jeder Spieler mir sofort öffnet, weil ich der und der Trainer bin. Das ist absolut individuell. Das kann ich aber ganz gut und auch relativ schnell einschätzen. Aber zeitlich kann ich ein Gespräch machen. Die Jungs sind ja alle anders. Jeder ist ja einmalig.
Das ist bei uns hier im Raum auch so. Wie hat sich denn die Haltung der Spieler verändert? Wenn ich mir jetzt angucke, zum Beispiel im Jahr 1999, Sie haben Ihren U19-Kader. Hat sich die Haltung der Spieler verändert, wie sie Ihnen als Trainerfigur begegnen?
Ich habe da, glaube ich, eine ziemlich starke, natürliche Autorität. Die habe ich, glaube ich, nicht trainiert. Meine Frau sagt immer, Gott sei Dank hast du das. Ich bin ja schon ein durchaus sensibler, feinfühliger Mensch, was nicht unbedingt ein Nachteil sein muss, wenn du Menschen führst. Ich bin da, glaube ich, sehr facettenreich, aber habe da mit der Autorität Gott sei Dank noch nie Probleme gehabt. Sonst ist es wie in einem – das ist eben so. Wenn du Menschen führst und es werden von dir Schwächen erkannt, das machen die gar nicht extra. Oder weil sie dich nicht leiden können, die Schwächen werden relativ schnell ausgenutzt, ob das Profis sind oder Jungprofis sind. Dann wirst du wie in einem Wolfshudel versuchen die Menschen dann relativ schnell deine Position unterbewusst einzunehmen. Sie wissen ja, dass sie da nicht Trainer werden können. Das war eigentlich schon immer so. Was sich verändert hat, ist sicherlich so dieser – es hat aber auch mit der Zeit, mit der Gesellschaft zu tun, der absolute Fokus auf Fußball. Zu meiner Zeit gab es nur Fußball, Fußball, Fußball. Heute bist du eben auch schneller auf diese – nach Malcolm Gladwell – diese zehn Jahre, 10.000 Stunden Fußball gekommen.
Ach, wenn man etwa 10.000 Stunden Fußball gemacht hat.
Ja, wobei das muss dann auch schon qualitativ hoch werden. Ja, genau. 10.000 Stunden rumpülen, da wirst du wahrscheinlich auch kein Profi. Aber dann bist du viel schneller auf diese Stunden gekommen. Weil heute für unsere Jungs ist das Vereinstraining der Fall. Und ansonsten sind die Freizeitmöglichkeiten, die Ablenkungsmöglichkeiten ja viel, viel größer. Über Digitalisierung, moderne Medien, Internet, Handy, Spielkonsolen. Viele, viele andere Dinge. Und von daher ist der Fokus heute – das kann man auch nicht verallgemeinern. Aber bei vielen eben nicht mehr so stark auf den Fußball, auf dieses große Ziel, also diesem Ziel wirklich alles unterzuordnen, und sonst wirst du das auch kaum schaffen können, ist häufig nicht mehr so stark.
Und das ist ja auch dann der Aspekt, der von vielen als eine Form der Bequemlichkeit kritisiert wird, wenn man es so formulieren möchte. Würden Sie das auch so sehen? Man kann das ja auch positiv deuten, dass heute junge Menschen nicht alles diesem einen Ziel unterordnen, bei dem ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man es erreicht, sehr, sehr gering ist, eben der Profifußball.
Ja, bin ich voll bei Ihnen. Von daher ist es auch immer wichtig, dass Arnold Schwarzenegger hat anders gedacht. Aber er war eben damals auch eine Ausnahmeerscheinung im Bodybuilding. Der hatte keine Alternative, hatte keinen Plan B. Dadurch kannst du natürlich auch nicht mehr zur Rock, es gibt nur den einen Weg. Aber da ist nur ein, zwei, drei, vier, fünf Prozent Schaffen. Bei allem Optimismus – und es ist wichtig, auch seinen Traum zu leben und an seinen Traum zu glauben – muss man trotzdem realistisch optimistisch dran gehen. Das bedeutet, dass du unbedingt einen Plan B brauchst. Das ist dann eben eine hochqualifizierte Schulausbildung, wenn eben möglich. Für viele hoffentlich dann auch Plan A, denn das werden die wenigsten schaffen. Für die meisten meiner Jungs ist Plan B schon für enorm wichtig, diesen Plan zu haben.
Und hören ihnen die Spieler auch zu, wenn sie ihnen sowas sagen? Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ja zu weit weg vom Fußballgeschäft, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass gerade junge Fußballer im Juniorenbereich von sehr vielen Ecken sehr viele Meinungen hören, weil es da schon Berater gibt, zum Teil schon Sponsoren. Eltern waren schon immer ein Faktor. Und jetzt aber tatsächlich auch über soziale Medien kommen quasi anonyme Stimmen mit dazu. Ist es schwieriger geworden, da zu den Spielern durchzudringen?
Nein. Also es gelingt mir immer noch, vielleicht auch aufgrund meiner Vita, weil wir hier gemeinsam in der Knappenschmiede doch große Erfolge hatten in den letzten beiden Jahrzehnten. Ja und nichts ist dann überzeugender als eben solche Erfolge auch. Aber ich bin da ganz bei Ihnen, dass die Einflüsse heute natürlich viel, viel größer sind. Damals gab es nur die Familie, gab es einen Trainer. Und heute ist das Umfeld, was die Spieler betrifft. Es gibt den Berater. Gegen die bin ich nicht grundsätzlich. Es gibt Athletiktrainer. Auch die Berater haben dann ihre Zusatztrainer noch für die Spieler. Also die Einflüsse sind heute sicherlich schon gewaltig, sodass es insgesamt schwerer geworden ist, die Spieler zu überzeugen und zu erreichen. Bei uns, bei mir gelingt das aber immer noch, egal aus welchen Gründen, immer noch ganz gut. Ein großes Problem sehe ich in der Überbetonung des Talents. Dass du zu früh hochgejubelt wirst, dass zu früh schon in dir ein kommender Profi gesehen wird. Und dass dadurch häufig Dinge wie Einstellung – oder ich setze nochmal woanders an. Ich sage ja immer wieder, dass Talent dich in ein Fenster stellt, in eine Tür stellt. Aber dass erst Anstrengungsbereitschaft, Einstellung, Charakter, Durchhaltevermögen, Willenskraft dich durch diese Tür hindurchbringen, will heißen, dass du auch ein Talent dafür brauchst, dein Talent zu nutzen, dass du ein Talent dafür brauchst, Hindernisse und Widerstände zu überwinden. Und das ist vielleicht einer der Ansätze, wenn sie mich mal später irgendwas anders fragen, warum wir hier doch ziemlich erfolgreich waren. Weil ohne Anstrengungsbereitschaft, ohne all diese Dinge, kommt hier bei mir keiner durch, keiner in den Profikader. Weil das einfach nicht stabil genug ist. Und wenn du, also wen die Götter zerstören wollen, wen die Medien zerstören wollen, den machst du ganz früh öffentlich zum Supertalent.
Ja, denn dann wird es doppelt und dreifach schwer. Und das Schlimmste ist, wenn die Spieler dann selbst auch das vielleicht glauben. Sie haben geschrieben in ihrem Buch, zu einem erfolgreichen Geleben gehören für sie fünf Eckpfeiler. Erstens Gesundheit, zweitens Familie, drittens Beruf, viertens Glaube bzw. Spiritualität und fünftens Finanzen. Theoretisch wären sie ja eigentlich nur für einen dieser Punkte jetzt zuständig im Leben ihrer Spieler, nämlich für den Beruf. Wie viel aus den anderen Lebensbereichen versuchen sie denn da noch mitzugeben?
Ja, zum nächsten Mal ist es ja selbstverständlich. Und das ist auch sehr erfreulich, aber irgendwo für mich auch selbstverständlich, das für jeden meiner Jungs. Wir führen vor jeder Saison meist im Trainingslager oder wenn wir danach bei Turnieren unterwegs, da haben wir viel Zeit, ein etwas längeres Einzelgespräch, wo ich dann auch mehr über den Menschen, über die Persönlichkeit, seine Herkunft, wie denkt David Tickter, seine Ziele, Träume erfahren möchte. Und da kommt immer wieder raus, wenn ich frage, was ist für dich das Allerwichtigste in deinem Leben? Das Allerwichtigste. Und dann kommt fast immer Familie. Und das ist gut so. Das freut mich, weil ich das genauso sehe. Das ist dein Stamm, da kommst du her. Oder auch später, wenn du dann verheiratet bist, selbst eine Familie gründest. Das sind die Menschen, die immer zu dir halten, egal wie gut du spielst oder wie schlecht. Gesundheit, der Bauschneid. Das ist ja klar, dass sie das auch verstehen. Ich sage meinen Jungs nichts von Schopenhauer, der gesagt hat, die Gesundheit ist nicht alles. Aber ohne die Gesundheit ist alles nichts. Ihr Körper ist ihr Kapital. Wenn du verletzt bist, spielst du nicht. Wenn du krank bist, spielst du nicht. Wenn du zu lange verletzt bist, krank bist, bist du weg vom Fenster. Also es ist ja klar, dass die Gesundheit ein ganz wichtiger Baustein ist. Und da kann ich mit meiner Historie glaube ich echt ein Lied von singen. Dann, mit Spiritualität meine ich einfach Glaube. Und da geht es mir nicht darum, wer an was glaubt. Zu welcher Religion, aber ich finde es schon wichtig. Für mich ist es wichtig, an eine höhere Instanz zu glauben. Da versuche ich meine Jungs aber nicht zu überzeugen. Wenn sie mich fragen, wenn sie sich mit mir darüber unterhalten wollen, dann ist das wichtig. Dann spreche ich darüber. Und Finanzen habe ich ja auch selber erfahren. Was, wenn du verschuldet bist, das ist nicht schön. Aber irgendwo hängen die Dinge alle miteinander. Du kannst genauso wenig wie du Taktik, Technik, Athletik, mentales Team zu sehr segmentieren solltest. Das macht man ja heute auch nicht mehr unbedingt. Wird aber immer noch ein bisschen getan. Kannst du diese Dinge, die gehören alle irgendwo zusammen für mich? Diese Säulen haben sich in meinem Leben, da habe ich zwar auch andere Menschen beeinflusst, aber die haben sich irgendwann bei mir so herauskristallisiert.
Also wir haben schon gelernt, sie lesen unheimlich viel. Ihr Buch ist auch voll von Motivationssprüchen und inspirierenden Anekdoten. Da sieht man, dass sie auch eben viel aus diesen Büchern mitnehmen. Manches lassen sie liegen und manches nehmen sie mit. Einiges davon findet man dann auch in ihrem Buch. Sie haben auch bei Ansprachen mit ihren Spielern schon in die Trickkiste gegriffen. Mit goldenen Handeln, mit zusammengebundenen Stöcken oder sogar einem lebendigen Hansen.
Zum Erfolg gibt es keine Tricks.
Okay, mit Trickkiste meine ich die Zauberkiste. Ich weiß natürlich, wie sie es gemeint haben. Besonders beeindruckt hat mich der lebendige Hase, also Hans der Angsthase, den sie mit in die Kabine genommen haben. Wie findet man bei so etwas die richtige Dosis? Das deuten sie ja auch an. Sie können jetzt nicht bei jedem Spiel kommen und sich irgendwas Neues überlegen, mit dem sie in einem Bild den Spielern etwas mitgeben wollen, was sich dann vor allem in ihrer Haltung auf dem Spielfeld ausdrückt.
Der Trainer Klaus Topmüller war ja ein sehr guter Trainer, ein sehr guter Motivator auch. Der hat in der Kabine bei Eintracht Frankfurt, glaube ich mal, das hat ja auch mit dem Wappen zu tun gehabt, der Eintracht einen Adler mitgebracht. Du kannst sowas – und das fand ich auch gut – Adler im Grunde genommen, edles Tier, steht für Kraft, für Energie, für Durchsetzungsvermögen. Das finde ich auch gut. Nur du kannst solche Dinge auch nur punktuell einsetzen. Das meinte ich ja damit. Du kannst dann – wie willst du das stoppen? In der nächsten Woche bringst du einen Löwen mit und dann irgendwann Elefanten. Solche Dinge werden von uns Trainern punktuell eingesetzt. Und so ist es auch immer wieder wichtig, dass man immer wieder auch mal zusätzlich motiviert durch Metaphern, durch Geschichten, die man erzählt. Aber das kannst du natürlich nur punktuell machen. Denn das Allerwichtigste ist die Eigenmotivation deiner Spieler. Wenn du permanent pushen und fremd motivieren musst, wird die Mannschaft dann irgendwann in sich zusammenfallen. Aber mit Geschichten, mit Metaphern zu arbeiten, um die rechte Gehirnhälfte zu erreichen. Wir haben ja zwei Gehirnhälften, es gibt sogar Wissenschaftler, die sagen drei, aber zwei reichen mir. Eigentlich linke und rechte Gehirnhälfte musst du beide erreichen. Wo die Gefühlswelt sitzt, wo die Intuition sitzt, die Kreativität, die erreichst du nicht mit Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken. Die linke Gehirnhälfte wiederum durch diese Dinge, wo der Verstand sitzt, wo das Urteilsvermögen sitzt und so weiter. Und so ist es wichtig, dass man im Grunde genommen, wenn du motivieren willst, auch beide Gehirnhälften anspricht.
Jetzt haben sie ja in ihrem Buch auch ganz viele Gastbeiträge, würde ich sie nennen, von ehemaligen Spielern vermehrt, auch zum Teil noch andere Personen aus ihrem Umfeld, also Benedikt Höwedes, Julian Draxler, Manuel Neuer, Sehat Kolasinac. Also da kann man die ganze Palette sehen und auch einige Namen, die man vielleicht so noch nicht gehört hat. Ist es jetzt Zufall, dass fast jeder von denen ein solches Ereignis hat, was eben oft nicht nur mit etwas verbunden ist, was sie gesagt haben, sondern auch mit etwas, was sie gemacht haben? Haben sie darum gebeten, dass die solche Anekdoten herausholen? Oder ist das dann das, woran sich die Menschen erinnern?
Ich freue mich über diese Frage. Zunächst einmal habe ich die Spieler nur kontaktiert um einen Gastbreitag gebeten. Habe mich dann aber rausgehalten. Und habe zu keinem gesagt, du schreib mal bitte was ganz Tolles über den Trainer, dass ich so richtig gut bei wegkomme. Wenn man das Buch so liest, könnte der Leser ja das ja meinen. Aber dem war nicht so. Ich sagte, schreib bitte ganz frei Dinge, die ihr erlebt habt. Das kann auch was sein, wo die dann sagen, um Himmels Willen, was ist das denn für ein Arschloch dieser Elgert? Also da seid ihr ganz frei drin. Dass sich manche Dinge überlappen, liegt in der Natur der Sache. Dass es auch teilweise unterschiedliche Dinge sind, liegt natürlich auch daran, dass man ihnen nicht in jeder Saison das Gleiche erzählt. Und dass jeder Mensch natürlich die Dinge anders für sich wahrnimmt. Der eine sagt vielleicht, was soll der Quatsch jetzt, da kann ich gar nichts mit anfangen. Und der andere sagt dann, boah, so wie man zum Beispiel sagt, in dem Spiel hätte ich die Welt, hätte ich Bäume ausreißen können. Das ist total individuell.
Aber es ist ja interessant, dass bei den Menschen, dass unser Kopf anscheinend so funktioniert, dass solche Taten, hätte ich es jetzt genannt, also eben ein Hase, der mitgebracht wird in die Kabine oder goldene Hand hin, dass sowas eher hängen bleibt, als auch ein paar Spieler haben auch auf Zitate von ihnen referiert oder auf Gespräche, gerade Benedikt Höwedes. Aber es scheint ja eher zu verfangen, dieses etwas objektifizierte, also dass man etwas mit einem Ding verbindet.
Ja, da ist ja auch jeder Mensch anders. Der eine ist eher eher in Bildern, visuell, und der andere ist eher auditiv, nimmt über die Ohren wahr.
Das sind natürlich alles Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und – Hörer.
Also das ist auch wieder, wir haben es ja mit, auch wenn in einer Mannschaft die Mannschaft an erster Stelle steht, also dass wir zuerst, haben wir es ja trotzdem mit Individuen zu tun. Also jeder Mensch ist ein Unikat, jeder Mensch ist einmalig. Es gibt keine, glaube ich nicht mal Zwillinge, die den gleichen genetischen Code haben. Und deswegen sind ja auch immer wieder zwei Dinge in der Führung wichtig. Dass wir, dass wir unsere Spieler oder die Menschen, die wir führen auch als Individuen, als Einmaligkeiten anerkennen. Dass wir eben nicht alles über einen Kamm scheren, sondern Gleichbehandlung heißt dann eher, jedem das zu geben, was er braucht. Und da ist jeder einzigartig. Aber jeder Mensch hat auch ein zweites großes Bedürfnis, wir haben viel mehr, ich schätze mal, in der Führung. Jeder möchte eigentlich auch Teil einer gemeinsam größeren Sache sein. Und beide Dinge ist es wichtig, dass man sie in der Menschen- und Mannschaftsführung auch berücksichtigt.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viel über diese weichen Faktoren gesprochen. Menschenführung, wie man individuell erreicht, Motivation. Was ist denn eigentlich Ihre Spielphilosophie? Lassen Sie uns mal über Fußball sprechen. Welchen Fußball wollen Sie spielen lassen?
Ja, Fußball total. Also für mich gibt es jetzt nicht nur den Ballbesitz Fußball oder nur Konterfußball oder nur auf den zweiten Ball gehen, sondern Fußball total. Fußball hat viel mit Situationen zu tun. Also ich habe gerne selber den Ball. Und dann musst du eben die Wege finden, die zum Spielziel eins sind, nämlich Tore zu schießen. Da gibt es eben das Ballbesitzspiel, was wir auch immer versuchen, sehr, sehr gut zu beherrschen. Dass wir versuchen, im Positionsangriff Wege zu finden. Da will ich jetzt aber auch nicht so sehr in die Tiefe gehen. Meine Kollegen hören ja vielleicht auch mit. Aber dass wir immer versuchen, Wege zu finden. Zum Gegner ist ein Tor ganz simpel. Das geht direkt über die Abwehr. Das geht aber vor allen Dingen, indem du immer wieder versuchst, Wege zu finden, hinter die Abwehr zu kommen oder auch zum nächsten Mal da vor, um dann da durchzukommen. Aber dazu gehört natürlich auch das Counterspiel. Dass wir versuchen, durch Gegenpressing, durch Angriffspressing sehr früh und sehr hoch den Ball zu gewinnen, weil wir dann einfach kürzere Wege haben zum gegnerischen Tor. Also ich würde das so als Fußball total bezeichnen. Meine Mannschaft oder wir haben gerne selber den Ball, weil das für mich auch der Ursprung des Spiels ist. Wir sind alle angefangen, keiner ist angefangen, Fußball zu spielen, mal egal wo, weil es so wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht, den Ball hinterherzulaufen. Es macht Spaß, den Ball zu haben. Das heißt, vereinfacht ausgedrückt, attackieren. Wenn wir den Ball haben, das ist gegnerische Tor. Wenn der Gegner den Ball hat, den Ball, damit wir den so schnell wie möglich wieder kriegen. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist die Basis einer ganz starken Offensive auch eine gute Defensive. Dass du als Mannschaft einfach auch kompakt stehen musst, dass du gegnerische Konter im Keime stickst, dass du gemeinsam gut verteidigst, dass du aber auch sehr stark bist in den Basics des Verteidigens und des Angreifens.
Also wenn ich ehrlich bin, überrascht mich die Antwort nicht. Sie wollen Tore schießen und sie wollen Tore verhindern. Ohne, dass sie mir jetzt ihre geheimen Pläne hier offenbar müssen, gibt es ja verschiedene Arten, das zu schaffen.
Das ist nicht so geheim, aber das alleine, da kann man ja nicht so ins Detail gehen. Das würde ja dann schon noch mal ein paar Stunden dauern.
Wir können ja kurze fünf Minuten. Es gibt ja verschiedene Schulen zum Beispiel des Ballbesitzfußballs. Es gibt das klare Positionsspiel, in dem der Ball rotiert, in dem das Bilden von Dreiecken wichtig ist. Das würde ich jetzt mal als spanische Schule bezeichnen. Ein bisschen unscharf, kann man auch noch andere dazu rechnen. Das ist so eine Art und Weise des Ballbesitzfußballs. Dann gibt es ja auch den Ballbesitzfußball, der eher in der letzten Reihe den Ball hat, bis sich beim Gegner einen Raum öffnet, weil der Gegner im Verschieben nicht aufmerksam genug war und dann wird in diesen Raum reingespielt. Welche Philosophie verfolgen Sie da? Steht die dann auch für Schalke 04 als Verein? Oder ist das jetzt einfach etwas, was Sie über die Jahre hinweg entwickelt haben?
Es geht im Fußball gar nicht so sehr um Systeme. Moderner Fußball ist vollkommen systemunabhängig. Es geht im Fußball vielmehr um Prinzipien. Und wenn wir über die Offensive sprechen, dann geht es ja nur darum, wie kommen wir dahin? Da hatte ich ja gerade schon mal gesagt, der erste Ansatz ist natürlich der Ballgewinn, um dann rein kontern zu können. Der Gegner ist offen, ist nicht formiert. Du hast kürzere Wege zum Tor und du musst weniger Gegenspieler überwinden, als wenn der Gegner formiert ist. Und wenn du selber den ballerst, dann gehören diese Prinzipien, aber nicht nur bei mir, die gehören einfach dazu. Es kommt natürlich darauf an, nicht nur Prinzipien zu haben, es kommt darauf an, sie zu trainieren und auch umzusetzen. Solche Dinge wie eine gute Raumaufteilung zu haben. Da haben mich schon die holländische Schule, die Käufschule, aber auch die spanische Schule, Barcelona schon sehr geprägt. Dass die Dreiecksbildung, die Rautenbildung, gehen wir noch einen Schritt weiter, von großer Bedeutung sind. Durch die Raute, gehen wir doch ein bisschen ins Detail, hast du eben viele Dreiecke und optimale Zuspielwinkel. Je mehr Rauten, desto mehr Dreiecke.
Vor allem das Direktspiel kann man dann…
Hast du auf dem Platz. Was wir anstreben durch unser Spiel, ist, wenn wir über die Kette spielen können, das hat ja auch was mit dem Prinzip Packing zu tun, dann haben wir den Gegner komplett ausgespielt. Dann machen wir das. Aber wenn der Gegner fällt, und das machen die ja meistens dann, in dem Moment, wo du diesen langen Ball ansetzt, dann macht das keinen Sinn. Dann ergeben sich für dich aber wieder Räume, in denen die sich fallen lassen, zwischen den Linien. Aber wir versuchen immer wieder so schnell wie möglich, und nicht durch so langen Ballbesitzfußball. Manchmal brauchst du mehr Pässe dafür, zwischen die gegnerischen Linien zu kommen. Und wenn du da bist, dann hast du nur noch vier oder fünf. Je nach Viererkette, manchmal auch Dreierkette, Adi Hütter. Wenn die hochgeschoben sind, sind manchmal nur drei, dann hast du in deinem Halbraum etwas mehr Platz. Dafür hat er aber vorher zwei, die mit attackieren können im Mittelfeld. Wenn wir da drin sind, dann haben wir schon mal etwas ganz Wichtiges erreicht. Und dann möchte ich, dass wir wellenförmig die Schnittstellen belaufen. Die Schnittstellen sind die Abstände zwischen zwei Spielern oder der Abstand zwischen einem Außenverteidiger und der Außenlinie. Dass wir die dann abgestimmt belaufen, dann sind wir ja schon im letzten Rittel. Um dann eben in die Box einzudringen, innen oder außen, je nachdem. Je nachdem, wo sich Platz ergibt. Und Platz ergibt, das Tor steht in der Mitte. Kannst du auch über die Mitte, über die Mittelzone oder über die Halbräume anstreben, aber auch über die Flügel. Und wenn wir möchten, immer möglichst über die Zentrale geht aber nicht immer. Dazu gehört dann eben auch eine gute Ballzirkulation. Du kommst nicht immer sofort zwischen den Linien oder dahinter. Du musst den Ball zirkulieren lassen. Dazu gehört es eben auch, den Gegner auf eine Seite zu locken, um dann die Spielverlagerung einzuleiten auf die andere Seite. Um in der Verlagerung aber musst du die Mitte auch weiter sehen. Weil du musst nicht unbedingt auf die andere Seite. Wenn du den Gegner auf die Seite gezogen hast, fängst du an zu verlagern. Aber die Zentrale geht es ja vielleicht auch da durch.
Das ist der schnellere Weg.
Also bei uns, bei mir, in meiner Philosophie, ist die Defensive sehr stark reglementiert. Sehr stark reglementiert. Trotzdem müssen die Spieler eigene Entscheidungen treffen, weil sie die Entscheidungen immer noch treffen. In der Offensive haben meine Spieler deutlich mehr Freiräume als bei vielen anderen Trainern. Da geht in Deutschland ja die Tendenz wieder so ein bisschen hin. Wir haben eine ganz andere Idee. Wir haben auch Matchpläne. Das musst du haben. Sonst handelst du fahrlässig. Wir wissen genau, wie wir spielen wollen, was wir wollen. Sind da aber auch Systemvariabel. Es gibt ganz einfache Prinzipien, die wir immer wieder haben. Wir wollen zwischen die Reihen, wir wollen dahinter. Wir wollen tiefe Vorbreite. Wir haben auch immer eine Idee, was den Spielaufbau betrifft, was das Übergangsspiel betrifft, das Endspiel betrifft. Endspiel heißt beim Schach. Spiel im letzten Drittel im Fußball. Aber insgesamt gebe ich schon immer meinen Spielern in der Offensive, bei aller Spielidee, die wir haben, deutlich mehr Freiheiten. Weil ich glaube, wenn wir in der Offensive zu sehr reglementieren, zu sehr vorschreiben, töten wir Kreativität und Intuition.
Das ist ja so eine der aktuellen Debatten. Da habe ich jetzt alles nachvollziehen können, was Sie gesagt haben. Sie müssen aber kurz bitte noch erklären, was meinen Sie mit dem wellenartigen Anlaufen der Schnittstellen? Also die Schnittstellen, das ist klar, aber inwiefern in Wellen? Wenn Sie mir das nochmal kurz erklären können.
Wellenförmig insofern, dass nicht alle gleichzeitig die Schnittstellen belaufen. Es ist ja wichtig, dass nicht zwei Spieler die gleiche Schnittstelle belaufen. Einer reicht. Es gibt verschiedene Schnittstellen. Wenn jetzt aber alle gleichzeitig starten, jeder in eine andere Schnittstelle, kann es vorkommen, dass alle gleichzeitig im Abseits stehen.
Okay, also es ist zeitlich gemacht, das Wellenartige.
Es hat mit Abseits zu tun. Es geht aber auch darum, dass es für den Gegner, wenn der Gegner, dass nämlich alle Katzen gleichzeitig in die Schnittstellen werden, die sich fallen lassen. Das sollen die ja nicht. Genau. Wir wollen ja vor der gegnerischen Linie, zum Beispiel frontal, parallel oder diagonal laufen, um dann rein zu starten. Machen das aber alle gleichzeitig. Der Gegner lässt sich fallen. Oder bleibt stehen, sind alle abseits. Oder der Gegner lässt sich eben fallen. Es ist für den Gegner deutlich schwerer zu verteidigen, wenn du in sogenannten Wellen da rein startest. Kann man aber auch sagen, einer nach dem anderen.
Okay, das ist jetzt, da könnte ich jetzt noch ewig mit Ihnen drüber reden, aber da kommen wir, finde ich, auch schon zu einem Kern, der gerade im Nachwuchsfußball dann nochmal interessanter ist als vielleicht im Profifußball. Denn die Basis von all dem, was Sie jetzt beschrieben haben, ist ja zum Beispiel der gut ausgeführte Pass und der gut verarbeitete Pass. Also, dass man es schafft, einen sauberen Pass zu spielen und dass der dann auch so weiterverarbeitet wird, dass ich eben das Feld vor mir habe, die Passoption im besten Fall vielleicht sogar direkt mit einem Kontakt weiter spielen kann. Sind diese Grundlagen alle schon gelegt bei den U19-Spielern, die sie bekommen? Oder ist das auch noch ein wesentlicher Teil ihrer Arbeit, erst mal dieses, ja, tatsächlich einfach das Fundament, auf dem letztlich der Fußball beruht, zu legen?
Also, zunächst mal kann ja jeder Spieler, egal wie alt oder wie gut, das betonen die aber auch selber. Auch die Ronaldos und die Bessies, die wollen immer noch besser werden. Aber das sind auch sehr, sehr gute Trainierer über Jahrzehnte, können immer noch besser werden. Was mir schon auffällt in den letzten Jahren, das Tempo ist höher geworden. Das Taktische ist wichtiger geworden und nicht unbedingt besser. Was aber auffällig ist, ist einfach auch im U19-Bereich die schwache Ballbeherrschung. Und der Ball ist das Spielgerät. Der Ball ist das Spielgerät und das musst du zunächst einmal beherrschen. Erst dann werden alle anderen Dinge wichtig. Das ist genauso wichtig oder vielleicht sogar noch ein Takt wichtiger. Das Spielverständnis, die Spielintelligenz, ist die Entscheidung zu treffen. Denn auf dem Platz, dadurch, dass sich alle Spieler – das ist ja nicht wie beim Schach, obwohl das schon schwer genug ist – alle Spieler bewegen sich ständig durcheinander. Die eigenen, die Gegner. Der Ball bewegt sich auch. Und du musst erkennen, was da passiert. Das meine ich dann auch mit Spielverständnis, Spielintelligenz. Denn nur, wenn du erkennst, was da auf dem Platz abgeht, was da passiert, und mit jeder Bewegung ist schon wieder alles anders, dann verstehst du ja das Spiel. Und nur, wenn du das Spiel verstehst, kannst du eine optimale taktische Entscheidung treffen. Hammerwichtig. Spielverständnis, taktisches Verständnis, Spielintelligenz. Wenn ich jetzt aber den Ball nicht beherrsche, ich habe jetzt eine taktische Entscheidung getroffen, also ich habe gesehen und ich habe verstanden und habe jetzt entschieden, womit ich ausführe, bin aber technisch zu schwach oder kann es nicht mit beiden Füßen. Kann ich keinen Spitzenfußballer sein? Also was ich sagen will, dass Fußball eigentlich ein ganz einfaches Spiel ist. Aber es auf ganz hohem Niveau zu spielen, ist komplex und schwer. Und da müssen wir wieder hin. Da müssen wir wieder hin. Das muss selbstverständlich sein, dass ein U19er oder ein U17er, U15er mit dem Spielgerät umgehen kann. Weil wenn er das nicht kann und der Raum, gehe ich nach Zeitdruck, wird immer größer, dann wird er da oben nicht spielen können. Und da glaube ich einfach, dass Wege gefunden werden müssen, um wieder auf diese vermeintlichen 10.000 Stunden oder zehn Jahre zu kommen. Ich glaube, dass unsere Spieler die noch nicht haben. Ich hatte das aber damals. Weil ich auf der Straße jeden Tag stundenlang gekickt habe. Weil ich Erfahrungen gesammelt habe. Und das jetzt einfach nur so in den Raum zu werfen, hilft ja noch nicht. Wir müssen es in Vereinstraining wieder reinbekommen. Durch Zusatzschichten, durch Veränderungen vielleicht der Ansätze auch im Training. Aber wir brauchen natürlich auch wieder. Wir kriegen ja Bolzplatz-Mentalität nur dadurch, indem wir Ersatz schaffen dafür. Wir sprechen schon lange darüber. Ich spreche schon lange darüber. Ich habe jetzt auch mal von Oliver B aufgehört. Oder von Michael Schönweiß auch vom DFB. Die denken da schon so ähnlich. Ein Ansatz wäre zum Beispiel – und ich glaube sogar, dass der praktikabel ist. Und das nicht nur die Leistungszentren. Auch die kleinen Vereine, die kleinen Gemeinden, da sind oft so tolle Trainer und haben so oft so tolle Plätze. Warum setzen wir da nicht Fußballspielplätze hin? Warum bieten wir nicht ab Mittags zum Beispiel Betreuung an? Da ist einer, der kümmert sich um euch, aber der schreibt euch nicht alles vor. Der kann euch mal Hilfestellung geben, aber der stellt euch Bälle, der stellt euch Trikots zur Verfügung. Wo du Fußballtennis spielen kannst, wo du eins gegen eins, zwei gegen zwei, Minitore, wo du drei gegen drei oder vielleicht auch nur mal auf Dosen, wie früher, wie wir. Wo du aber auch einfach auch ein Tor hast, wo du schießen kannst, wo du Fußballwände hast, wo du aber auch klettern, springen, Koordination usw. machen kannst. Da gibt es ja schon Vereine, die machen sowas, Ansätze. Wäre mal ein Ansatz, um einfach, wie kommst du sonst auf diese Stunden? Kommst du nicht mehr? Und dann wird die Technik auf der Strecke bleiben. Weil du brauchst diese Zeit. Und du lernst als junger Mensch einen Tag schneller. Du kannst dich lebenslang verbessern. Aber du kannst dich in, man spricht ja immer vom goldenen Lernalter um die zwölf Jahre. Das B- und A-Jugendalter ist noch mal ein goldenes Lernalter. Du kannst dich immer weiter verbessern. Aber du brauchst, die müssen wieder auf diese Stunden kommen, sonst wirst du den Ball nicht so beherrschen. Es ist teilweise grausam, sich anzusehen. Wenn der Ball verspringt, das Spielgerät nicht das macht, was du willst, dann hast du, wenn du mit dem Ball kämpfst, wie soll ich dann mit dem Gegner kämpfen? Schaff ich doch gar nicht. Das schließt sich aus.
Also letztlich soll ja wieder mehr Fußball gespielt werden. Würde das dann auch bedeuten, vor allem in jüngerem Alter, also jetzt nicht im U19-Bereich. Sie sind ja der Übergang in den Leistungsbereich. Sie müssen die Spieler vorbereiten, auch dass sie es potenziell schaffen könnten, in den Profibereich zu kommen. Aber in den vorgelagerten Bereichen müsste da nicht vielleicht auch wieder Fußball mehr als Spiel verstanden werden und weniger als wir haben jetzt 3 zu 0 gewonnen oder wir haben 3 zu 4 verloren?
Es gibt ja Ansätze, das Resultat abzuschaffen. Ich kann den Ansatz verstehen. Nur ich bin nicht ganz dabei, weil schon die Kleinsten wollen wissen, wie das Spiel ausgeht.
Irgendjemand zählt immer mehr.
Ja, die wollen wissen, wie das Spiel ausgeht. Ich würde das Resultat beibehalten. Wir müssen da den Druck rausbekommen. Wenn die Kleinsten schon immer extrem Ergebnisdruck haben, natürlich sollen sie gewinnen wollen. Aber wenn da schon Gewinnmüssen dazu kommt – Gewinnen müssen macht immer schwach, Gewinnen wollen macht eher stark – ich würde da so ein bisschen vom Resultatsdruck weggehen. Dazu muss man aber auch dahin kommen, dass die Vereine nicht nur sagen, unsere Trainer haben keinen Resultatsdruck bei den Kleinsten, sondern dass es wirklich auch gelebt wird. Denn die Wahrheit ist doch dann hinterher, wenn der fünfmal verliert, wenn einer hier mit der Schalker D-Jugend fünfmal verliert, dann wird es eben, so sehr man das vorher auch propagiert hat, alles in Frage gestellt. Da sollten wir schon weg vom Resultatsdruck uns viel stärker auf Entwicklung und Prozesse fokussieren. Denn wenn die Spieler sich gemeinsam und individuell weiterentwickeln und verbessern, wirst du automatisch häufiger gewinnen. Aber es muss eben mehr der Umgang mit dem Spielgerät und das Spiel an sich im Vordergrund stehen. Und nicht irgendwelche Spieleideen und Strategien. Mal so ein Beispiel, was auch jeder versteht. Wenn da in der E- und D-Jugend schon extrem Ball verschoben wird, dann ist das natürlich totaler Humbug. Oder wenn sowas dann auch noch trainiert wird, anstatt sich fußballisch zu verbessern.
Na gut, man kann das verschieben in der Kette, aber das bringt halt noch nicht den Rest mit.
Das Verschieben machen die in der E- und D-Jugend von alleine, weil immer noch alle zum Ball fließen. Die Ballorientierung ist automatisch da.
Sie haben ja auch in Ihrem Buch geschrieben, Zitat, um schnell nach oben zu kommen, stehen im Kinder- und Jugendfußball häufig auch Spieleidee, Taktik und Matchplan zu sehr im Vordergrund. Das ist das, was Sie gerade gesagt haben. Vernachlässigt werden dadurch Technik, Kreativität und Spielfreude. Und da musste ich spontan einmal mit Joel denken, der das ja in anderen Worten, in etwas markigeren Worten, mit das heutzutage die Kinder, wenn sie Fußball gelernt haben, mit zwölf Systeme rückwärts furzen können, aber keinen Ball behandeln können. Das ist doch im Grunde genau die gleiche Kritik, nur nochmal anders formuliert.
Ja, ich sehe es differenzierter, weil er hat ja so, glaube ich, großen Respekt vor ehemals Fußballspieler, auch was seine Ansätze betrifft. Ich sehe es teilweise auch so wie er, nur nicht vollständig. Also mir ist es immer zu sehr schubladend denken, wenn man alle Jugendtrainer heute dann als Laptoptrainer bezeichnet. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob er das so genau getan hat, aber es ging ja ein bisschen in die Richtung. Also es gibt da unter den Jugendtrainer schon hervorragende Profitrainer, aber auch hervorragende Jugendtrainer. In einer Sache bin ich natürlich dabei. Das hatte ich ja gerade auch gesagt, dass es Altersstufen gibt, in denen diese hochtaktischen Dinge unwichtig sind und sich sogar entwickeln mit den Jahren. Indem du implizit schulst, das heißt, mehr durch Spielformen, mehr begleitet, statt im Profibereich wird explizit trainiert. Klar, dass du mehr coachen musst, dass du mehr anleitest, dass du deine Vorstellung rüberbringst. Im Kinder- und Jugendbereich sollte mehr implizit trainiert werden, das heißt, mehr begleitet, den Ball noch mehr in den Vordergrund stellen, über Spielformen Dinge anstreben, ihnen nicht alles vorgeben. Wenn du zum Beispiel das 1-2-Kontaktspiel forcieren willst, muss man in den Altersstufen nicht unbedingt. Das ist nur ein Beispiel. Dann kann ich auch Spielformen den Spielern an die Hand geben, wo das automatisch sich ergibt. Oder ich kann sagen, ich erwarte von euch, dass ihr mit 1-2 Kontakt spielt. Das ist dann wieder explizit. Mehr Freiheiten lassen, mehr Spielformen, mehr sogenannte Small-Sided Games hat extrem viele Vorteile. Ein großer Vorteil ist zum Beispiel, wird die Technik gleich wieder mit trainiert. Mehr Ballkontakte. 11 gegen 11 sagen die Leute, die das untersucht haben. Zwei Ballkontakte vielleicht in einer Minute, wenn überhaupt. Sechs gegen sechs, vier. Vier gegen vier, sechs Kontakte. Mehr Ballkontakte, mehr Entscheidungen treffen. Und wenn ich in vier gegen vier spiele, oder in fünf gegen fünf, habe ich auch schon hochtraktische Dinge mit drin. Wie zum Beispiel, was die Offensive betrifft, Dreiecksbildung, Rautenbildung hat auch da Vorteile. Kann man sich aber gemeinsam erarbeiten. Durch Guided Discovery viele Fragen stellen. Aber in vielen Bereichen bin ich da schon, bin ich da sehr bei eben nicht in allen. Muss ja auch nicht sein.
Und ist das eine Diskussion, die jetzt auf ihrer Ebene der Trainer – Sie sind ja auch sicher gut vernetzt – geführt wird? Denn ich habe das Gefühl, das poppt immer mal wieder so auf. Und das wird dann immer auch aufgehängt, vor allem am Abschneiden der deutschen Vereine und der Nationalmannschaft. Und dann kommt auch ein Oliver Bierhoff und sagt, wir wollen jetzt mehr Ballplatz-Mentalität, wir wollen Kreativität fördern, wir wollen wieder schnellere Spieler haben. Und dann wirkt das auf mich immer, als wäre dann damit die Diskussion, die eigentlich gar keine war, beendet.
Das wird man sehen. Ich hatte ein langes Gespräch über zwei Stunden mit dem Michael Schönwald, Chefausbilder jetzt beim DFB, den ich fachlich und menschlich auch sehr schätze. Also die Ansätze, die finde ich schon hochspannend. Ich gehe jetzt nicht in allen Dingen mit. Zum Beispiel, wenn es um Resultate geht in verschiedenen Alterstufen. Aber es ist, glaube ich, auch zunächst mal zur Diskussion gebracht worden. Das sind ja Ansätze, die sie haben. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit sie dann schon beschlossen sind, was dann kommen wird. Aber eins bin ich dabei. Das müssen wir abwarten. Wissen ist wenig, können ist König. An ihren Taten sollst du sie erkennen. Warten wir mal ab.
Ja, ich stelle mir da ehrlich gesagt immer eine übergeordnete Frage. Wenn es heißt, es soll wieder mehr Kreativität im Fußball gefördert werden, dann bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob – ich sage jetzt einfach mal der Deutsch, auch wenn es den Deutsch nicht gibt – aber Journalisten, Fans und zum Teil vielleicht auch Trainer, ob wir das überhaupt aushalten. Denn zur Kreativität gehören ja immer die Dinge, die nicht geklappt haben, genauso mit dazu. Also die drei ersten Pässe können fürchterlich schiefgehen und alle im Stadion stöhnen auf. Und dann würde es ja bedeuten, dass wir alle wollen, dieser Spieler soll jetzt bitte nochmal den vierten Pass passieren, denn Kreativität ist ja nicht über 90 Minuten da. Kreativität sind einzelne Momente. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Fußball so wie er heutzutage analysiert und seziert wird, auch von Leuten wie mir im Rasenfunk, ob das überhaupt noch eine Projektionsfläche ist, wo man das wirklich aushält, dass jemand kreativ ist, dass wir ihm auch mal zugestehen, dass er um konventionelle Wege geht, auch wenn er die ersten vier Mal gegen die Tür läuft, und beim fünften Mal geht er dann erst durch.
Bin ich dabei? Bin ich voll bei Ihnen? Es muss nach wie vor erfolgreich sein oder noch erfolgreicher. Und wir müssen auch nicht alles verteufeln, denn selbstverständlich gehört ein Matchplan heute. Gehört eine Spielidee dazu. Aber ich finde, das Ganze sollte sich vor allen Dingen aufbauen aufgrund, zunächst einmal die erste Säule müsste sein, die eigene Stärken. Die eigenen Stärken. Wir müssen den Gegner analysieren. Wir müssen die Schwächen und Stärken des Gegners können, um Gegenstrategien zu entwickeln. Aber ich halte es für viel wichtiger, wie spielen wir? Was ist unser Spiel? Wie wollen wir uns durchsetzen? Das hat natürlich mit den Stärken und Schwächen des Gegners zu tun. Das schließt sich aber nicht aus. Aber eines ist doch klar. Wir dürfen natürlich auch nicht schulen, dass der Innenverteidiger sich hinten den Ball nimmt. Wir sollen jetzt kreativ und mutig sein. Und jetzt mache ich den mal alle frisch und haue den rein. Oder ich spiele jetzt nur noch Risikopässe in der Spieleröffnung. Damit spiele ich dem Gegner von fünf Pässen vier in den Konter rein. Trotzdem müssen wir natürlich hingehen und auch am Beispiel des Innenverteidigers das durchaus mal einfordern, dass der den Ball zwischen die näggegegnischen Reihen durchpeitscht. Aber dann wird es ja schon wieder taktisch. Wie stehst du dann als Formation? Voraussetzung dafür ist natürlich dann, dass du zwar so viel Tiefe wie möglich im Spiel hast, aber nur so viel Breite wie nötig. Und wenn der diesen Risikoball durch zwei, durch dieses Nadelöhr durchpeitscht und du verlierst den Ball, dass du sofort wieder in die Chance des Gegenpressing gehst. Denn dann ist so ein Ballverlust ja vielleicht sogar ein Vorteil. Aber wir müssen beides schulen. Risiko ja, aber wo befinde ich mich auf dem Feld und wie gehe ich mit diesem Risiko um? Also ich kann ja nicht jetzt zum Innenverteidiger sagen, noch mal gerade, du gehst jetzt nur volles Risiko oder der Außenverteidiger oder der Sechser. Der fängt jetzt nur noch an. Aber wir müssen auch mal in der Spieleröffnung, im Übergangsspiel ein höheres Risiko gehen. Du musst dich nur klug verhalten, damit du nicht jedes Mal den Kontakt kriegst und kriegst die Bude voll dahin. Das werden die Zuschauer nicht mitmachen, das werden die Medien nicht mitmachen. Das schließt aber nicht aus, dass wir Kreativität fördern, dass wir Intuition fördern, dass ein Spieler sich traut, auf dem Platz, auch im Mittelfeld, was Verrücktes zu machen. Aber das eben nicht permanent. Jetzt muss ja nicht jeder gleich im Umkehrschloss, wo er sich bewegt, seine Pirouetten machen. Aber im letzten Drittel…
Es gibt eben Ort für Kreativität, das ist eben das letzte Drittel.
Ja, das finde ich sehr gut.
So ein bisschen wie der Bastelraum im Kindergarten.
Ich kann ja auch hinten mal kreativ sein, ohne jetzt ein übergroßes Risiko einzugehen. Aber Risiko, Mut eigentlich überall, mit Abstrichen hinten und im defensiven Mittelfeld. Aber vorne müssen sie sich einfach trauen. Und ich glaube einfach, dass das auch ein bisschen mit unserer Philosophie zu tun hat. Dass hier viele Kreativspieler rausgekommen sind. Nicht nur Leroy, Julian Draxler. Er ist mir ein bisschen zu sehr davon abgekommen. Ich würde gerne sehen, dass er auch bei Paris wieder mehr in sein Dribbling reingeht. Weil das ist eine große Stärke. Max Meyer. Und sicherlich noch der eine oder andere mehr. Auch Manuel Neuer ist ein Kreativtorwart. Der traut sich was. Da müssen wir wieder hin, dass sich Spieler einfach trauen, dass du das sogar einforderst. Und so ein bisschen bei der U21 meine ich, ich habe nicht viel gesehen, weil ich im Urlaub war, konnte man es sehen. Dass man eben wirklich drauf geht. Dass man durch ein gewonnenes 1 gegen 1 oder 2 Spieler hinter sich lässt, der Gegner anfangen muss zu springen, neue Spielsituationen schafft. Es geht eben nicht nur mit passend, passend, passend, passend.
Ja, das konnte man tatsächlich bei dieser U21 EM betrachten. Aber wenn Sie jetzt hier schon Spieler wie eben Leroy Sané, Misut Özil und so weiter, Max Maier nennen, haben Sie denn eine Idee, wie viele Spieler, die jetzt in diesen, Sie gehen jetzt in Ihre 24. Saison als U19-Trainer, ich, ich, Ja, wenn man die Co-Trainerzeit unter Frank Neubert mit dazuzählt. Das ist ja so ein bisschen so eine Dreiviertelsaison, die fehlt.
Also eine Schwangerschaft.
Runden wir ab, sagen wir einfach 23 Jahre. Es ist ja trotzdem sehr, sehr lange. Haben Sie denn eine Idee, wie viele Spieler da durch ihre Hände gegangen sind, die mindestens ein Erstligaspiel gemacht haben?
Wir sind keine Statistiker, aber es sind verdammt viele.
Es sind 105 Spieler, die insgesamt fast auf 4.400 Erstligapartien kommen. Und jetzt nur erste Fußball-Bundesliga. Ich habe jetzt nicht noch internationale.
Danke für Ihre Recherche. Ich bin kein Statistiker, aber das freut mich natürlich sehr und nicht schlecht. Ich hätte es so bei 80 eingestuft.
Nein, es sind tatsächlich 105. Ich habe da noch für ein paar Vergleichsvereine…
Das müssen wir veröffentlichen.
Das können Sie wegen mir sehr gerne machen. Wenn Sie noch einen Link zu dieser Folge mit dazu packen, dann kriege ich ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit. Ich habe das Ganze noch verglichen mit den Jugendabteilungen vom VfB Stuttgart, FC Bayern, Borussia Dortmund, HSV und Hertha BSC. Ich habe das nicht für alle Jugendabteilungen gemacht, aber für die sechs. Da habe ich einen interessanten Trend festgestellt. Zum einen gibt es tatsächlich noch eine Mannschaft, die mehr Spieler in der Zeit vorgebracht hat. Das ist der VfB Stuttgart. 115 Spieler mit 6.800 Spielern. Die hatten einen sehr guten Lauf in der Jugendarbeit. Aber was allen Mannschaften gemein ist, die diesen genannten, ist, dass es wesentlich zurückgegangen ist. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf die letzten zehn Jahre gucke, also bis zum Jahr 1991 bei den Spielern, dann kommen sie immer noch auf 38 Spieler, die Erstligaspiele gemacht haben, auch über 1000 Spiele. Also da sind noch sehr viele mit dabei. Und wenn ich jetzt aber auf die letzten fünf Jahre gucke, dann gibt es noch Positivbeispiele wie zum Beispiel Schalke 04 mit 16 Spielern und 217 Spielen, wie zum Beispiel auch Dortmund mit 12 Spielern und 229 Spielen. Da waren dann schon so einzelne Karrieren mit dabei. Aber zum Beispiel gibt es da auch einen FC Bayern, die haben zwar 17 Spieler in die erste Liga gebracht in diesem Zeitraum, nominell am meisten, aber diese Spieler haben 51 Spiele.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden, dass der Trend eher unseren Weg verstärkt?
Genau. Der Trend ist so, dass es bei allen Vereinen, auch Schalke, zurückgeht, was die eingesetzten Spieler gibt, die eben durch die U19 gelaufen sind und dann in der ersten Liga debütiert haben. Das Schalke aber noch zusammen mit – ich würde da jetzt den BVB dazurechnen, wenn man möchte den VfB noch dazurechnen, da liegt es aber ehrlich gesagt an drei, vier Einzelkarrieren. Aber Schalke ist noch der Vereine, der diesem Trend noch am ehesten widersteht, dass er eben rückgängig ist. Aber bei allen Vereinen ist zu sehen, es geht zurück, dass eigene Jugendspieler entweder in der eigenen Mannschaft oder irgendwo beim Erstligateam Spielminuten bekommen. Woran, würden Sie sagen, liegt das?
Woanders kann ich natürlich nicht einschätzen. Bei uns in den letzten Jahren – jetzt muss ich selber mal ein bisschen nachdenken und zurückgehen, waren es jetzt die letzten waren – Gotuchu, Bourgelap, McKennie. Sicherlich, meiner Meinung nach, und ich darf das auch öffentlich tun, oder habe ich schon immer getan, haben wir zu viele Eigengewächse abgegeben, die…
Noch im Status des Eigengewächses?
Ja, auch danach, die aber alle natürlich schon in dieser Statistik zu finden sind, wie Thilo Kehrer und so weiter, die nicht mehr bei uns spielen. Aber im Moment sind wir da noch ganz gut dabei. Woanders kann ich das nicht einschätzen. Ich werde gleich mal ein bisschen ausführlicher. Wir haben in den letzten Jahren sicherlich einiges mit den gerade genannten Spielern geschafft. Wir haben unser Soll, wobei das schwierig ist, es gibt eben unterschiedliche Jahrgänge, immer noch erfüllt. Wir haben in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren, ohne da jetzt irgendwo Nachzugarten oder irgendjemanden anzupangern, da werde ich auch niemanden wörtlich nennen, widerspricht unseren Prinzipien, etwas zu wenig getan. Wir haben uns zu sehr darauf verlassen, dass auf die Draxlers, Neuers, die ja auch hier nach oben gekommen sind und haben aber zu wenig getan in Sachen Quereinsteiger. Von den anderen gab es noch jede Menge Karneiern und und und Quereinsteiger, Mesut Özil, Sehat Kolasinac, Wes McKennie, da haben wir zu wenig getan. Da ist inzwischen aber die Bereitschaft wieder deutlich höher, mehr zu tun. Bevor ich hinaus will, alle, die mal Bundesliga gespielt haben, haben alle irgendwo mal vorher Jugend gespielt. Daraus ergibt sich für mich eigentlich eine ganz einfache Rechnung. Irgendwo müssen die ja herkommen und dann ist es doch besser, wenn du sie selber ausbildest, ob sehr früh oder später dazu holst und ihnen dann den allerletzten Schliff gibst. Das ist immer noch besser, weil erstens kostengünstiger. Zweitens ist die Identifikation mit Spielern, die aus den eigenen Reihen kommen, häufig noch mal ein bisschen größer. Es hat also nur Vorteile. Warum das rückläufig ist, weiß ich nicht. Bei uns, wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würden, warum, weshalb, einen Stein der Weisen habe ich nicht, immer noch nicht gefunden. Ich weiß eher, dass ich nichts weiß. Ich glaube aber, manchmal ist es so, weil wir schon dazu stehen sollten, bei aller Demut, wir sind da nicht besser oder wir heben uns nicht über andere, weil andere bilden ähnlich oder genauso gut teilweise sogar besser aus. Aber wenn – eine andere Erklärung habe ich auch nicht – wenn besondere Umstände und Menschen aufeinandertreffen, dann kann sowas mal passieren. Schauen Sie mal, wenn Sie sich mit dem Buch – das werden Sie garantiert, vielleicht haben Sie sogar gelesen – von dem englischen Tischtennisspieler Bounce. Das gibt es auch in Deutsch. Der hat sich sehr stark mit Talent und so weiter befasst. Es ist immer wieder spannend – vielleicht schauen Sie mal rein – dass es immer wieder Akademien gibt, wo erstaunlich viele – kann keiner so richtig erklären – gibt es nur Ansätze. Im Tischtennis gab es zum Beispiel eine Straße in England, wo mit Abstand die meisten Tischtennisspieler aus England herkamen. So etwas gibt es scheinbar auch im Fußball.
Es gibt ja auch die berühmten goldenen Jahrgänge, wo dann mit einem Mal fünf Nachwuchsspieler im Profifußball landen. Dann kommt der nächste Jahrgang, wo dann wieder das normale Eintritt, nämlich dass es nur ein bis zwei schaffen. Dann wird das aber so interpretiert, als wäre einmal besonders gute Arbeit gemacht worden und einmal besonders oder nicht ganz so gut. Aber gut, da sind wir uns, glaube ich, sowieso beide einig. Da müssen wir nicht tiefer drauf eingehen. Aber was mich da interessieren würde, ist, eine Komponente gibt es natürlich, die sich jetzt in den letzten fünf bis vielleicht zehn Jahren verändert hat. Nämlich, es gibt ein paar neue – ja, Neudeutsch würde man sagen – Player auf dem Nachwuchsmarkt. Also wir haben zum Beispiel mit der TSG aus Hoffenheim, wenn ich auf die Spieler der letzten fünf Jahre blicke, muss ich die eigentlich mit berücksichtigen. Es ist eigentlich nicht ganz richtig, dass ich die hier rauslasse. Wir haben zum Beispiel mit Rasenballspot Leipzig einen neuen Player, der zwar aus der eigenen Jugend jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel in den Profifußball gebracht hat, aber da könnten wir ja dann die Jugend, da können wir ja dann Liefering und Salzburg und so weiter, müsste man da eigentlich mit in die Betrachtung mit einbeziehen. Was hat sich denn da verändert? Jetzt wenn wir nur mal auf den Nachwuchsfußball in Deutschland gucken, in den letzten Jahren, hat da so auch so ein Verein wie Schalke auch damit zu tun, dass es da jetzt einfach auch andere Konzepte gibt, andere Angebote und sich die regionale Strahlkraft ein bisschen verschiebt?
Der Konkurrenzkampf war immer schon sehr groß, auch in den Jahren, wo mehr Topspieler rausgekommen sind. Aber er hat sich definitiv natürlich nochmal verstärkt. Also der Kampf – es sind ja in erster Linie Menschen, das hört sich schrecklich an – der Kampf um die Talente, der Wettbewerb um die Talente, aber auch um Vereinserfolg, der hat sich natürlich nochmal deutlich verstärkt. Einmal dadurch, dass das Ausland auch verstärkt in diesen Bereichen aktiv geworden ist, England, Frankreich, wo man im Moment ja auch sehr erfolgreich ist, aber vor allen Dingen natürlich auch national. Haben Sie ja gerade schon gesagt, der Vereine, die häufig gar nicht genannt werden, Wolfsburg im Jugendbereich, die durch die großen Leistungszentren, durch immer mehr Internatsplätze, die müssen natürlich auch gefüllt werden. Und Spieler werden teilweise immer früher auch in die Leistungszentren geholt, teilweise viel zu früh. Hat aber eben damit zu tun, dass die Vereine sagen, wenn wir es nicht tun, dann machen es die anderen. Da gibt es ja zu wenig Agremens dann in diesen Bereichen, was die Altersstufen betrifft. Aber Sie haben es gerade schon gesagt, Hoffenheim ist dazugekommen, Leipzig ist dazugekommen mit hervorragenden Möglichkeiten, Infrastrukturen, aber auch mit entsprechend interessanten Philosophien. Und da sind ja jetzt nur einige wenige. Wir könnten ja, glaube ich, noch viele mehr nennen. Wir haben hier bei uns in der Gegend zum Beispiel auch MSV Duisburg VfL Bochum, die jedes Jahr mitmischen auch in der A- und B-Jugendbundesliga, die hervorragend ausbilden und dir auch was zu bieten haben. Kein Bayern München, kein Borussia Dortmund, kein Schalke 04 ist ja der Nabel der Welt. Das Angebot der Vereine ist erstklassig und da muss jeder Verein eben seinen eigenen Weg finden. Aber du hast eben nicht die Garantie, weil du das und das hast, dass du jetzt alle Spieler bekommst. Man muss sich da auch in anderen Dingen unterscheiden. Und da bin ich immer wieder für den, mögen andere aber auch tun, für den sehr ganzheitlichen Ansatz. Das ist definitiv kein Zufall. Aber ich könnte es ihnen jetzt auch nicht sagen im Detail. Ich habe auch nur Vermutung. Warum gelingt es uns hier immer wieder. Dass Spieler sehr früh eine gute Rolle spielen können in der ersten Mannschaft? Jetzt ist es im Moment im letzten Jahr natürlich leichter gewesen. Ganz klar, dann ist es dann schwerer, eben bei Bayern zu spielen. Aber warum haben so viele geschafft? Da hat man ja selber auch nur Ansätze. Sobald man dann nämlich meint, wir haben es gefunden, dann ist man weg vom Fenster. Aber immer wieder der ganzheitliche Ansatz, immer wieder für die Spieler da sein, ihnen alles geben, was du hast, immer wieder auf allerhöchstem Niveau, in sämtlichen Bereichen arbeiten und trainieren, selbstverständlich, aber auch immer wieder es ihnen schwer machen. Denn Allianz Arena zu spielen oder in Dortmund oder in Leipzig zu spielen, ist sau schwer. Und wenn es vorher leicht war, wie willst du das Schwere denn dann schaffen?
Wie wichtig ist denn da das sportliche Abschneiden der Herrenmannschaft für jetzt zum Beispiel, um Spieler davon zu überzeugen, auch jetzt zum Beispiel zu U19 von Schalke 04 zu kommen? Macht sich da so eine sportliche Misere wie jetzt in der letzten Saison, wenn das anhalten würde, würde sich sowas bemerkbar machen?
Spielschwierigkeit hat keine große Rolle, weil im Grunde genommen bin ich schwächer, die Profi-Mannschaft, umso leichter kommste da rein.
Also es geht eher um die Durchlässigkeit, dass man nachweisen kann, vor dir haben.
Ja, es geht um die Durchlässigkeit. Es geht ein großer Vorteil. Es ist sicherlich, dass wir sagen können, wie viele Spieler es hier schon geschafft haben. Und nochmal bei aller Bescheidenheit ein kleiner Vorteil bin ich dann auch noch da, betone aber immer wieder, dass die Knappenschmiede keine One-Man-Show ist. Wir haben viele sehr, sehr gute Mitarbeiter und Trainer. Aber Liga-Zugehörigkeit könnte noch eine große Rolle spielen. Da ist die erste Liga vielleicht schon wichtig. Aber entscheidend ist, was ist da passiert in den vergangenen Jahren? Und wie will der Verein das auch weiterhin? Und da ist sicherlich das Überzeugendste immer noch der Erfolg der letzten Jahre. Was ist da passiert? Denn du kannst viel erzählen, aber das ist viel, viel wichtiger.
Und das ist jetzt der heilige Grala. Bin ich gespannt, ob sie mir das jetzt erklären können. Warum gibt es auf Schalke immer so hohe Höhen und so tiefe Tiefen?
Profimannschaft, boah, in den letzten Jahren, also Höhen und Tiefen. Es gab ja schon mal verdammt viele Jahre, die extrem gut waren, hier auch bei uns. Viele Jahre hintereinander. Der Anspruch ist, sobald es anfängt zu laufen, wird immer höher. Das war ja damals Vizemeisterschaft und waren dann auf einmal schon wieder nichts. Was wären wir froh, jetzt, vor zwei Jahren, waren wir es, mit dem Misserfolgsjahr des letzten Jahres. Also Schalke 04 hat eine lange, lange Tradition. Und man ist früher, ganz früher, ganz oft Deutscher Meister geworden. Und ich glaube, die Leute sehnen sich sowas von extrem danach, dass man immer wieder, jetzt haben wir es, und dann wieder nicht. Einmal Vize damals, wo Mikos Lombka fast Deutscher Meister geworden wäre, mit großem Vorsprung dann hinterher noch zurückgefallen. Die Leute sehnen sich sehr danach, sowas mal wieder zu erleben. Ja, ich glaube, dass wir hier, ich schätze unseren Menschen, ich gehöre selber dazu, wobei ich eigentlich nicht in solchen Kategorien denke, eher als Kosmopolit, aber ich bin hier geboren, gerne geboren, stehe auch dazu, bin auch stolz darauf. Man neigt hier eher, vielleicht der Deutsche im Allgemeinen, aber auch immer wieder zu himmelhoch jauchzend und zu Tode betrübt. Das wird zu sehr, wenn es hier mal negativ läuft, dass es extrem verstärkt wird durch Öffentlichkeit, durch Medien auch. Und dass wir sobald es anfängt zu laufen, dann meint man sofort wieder so, jetzt haben wir es, so ein bisschen mehr dazwischen uns bewegen und nicht so sehr den Misserfolg und den Erfolg überhöhen, würde uns hier, glaube ich, gut tun. Aber vielleicht wäre Schalker noch nicht mehr Schalker.
Das kann natürlich sein, ja. Und das ist ja auch ein bisschen bezeichnend für unsere Zeit. Glauben Sie denn, dass dieses Malocher-Image, was Sie vorhin auch ganz am Anfang haben Sie auch mal darauf referiert und das Sie wollen auch sehen von Ihren Spielern, dass Sie alles gegeben haben auf dem Platz, steht das vielleicht Schalke 04 als Verein manchmal auch im Weg, weil das in der Kader-Zusammenstellung solche Spielertypen bevorzugt und man vielleicht aber beides braucht, also sowohl denjenigen, der richtig malochen kann, als auch die feine Klinge. Und es gibt eben ganz selten die Spieler, wo beides zusammenkommt.
Ja, aber eines sollte doch selbstverständlich sein. Ich glaube gar nicht mal so, dass diejenigen, die dafür zuständig waren für die Einkäufe oder sind, dass die so sehr in diesen Kategorien gedacht haben. Jetzt stelle ich mal die rhetorische Frage, die ich ja von alleine beantworte. Ist es nicht für jeden Fußballer, selbst wenn er in der Kreisliga spielt und dann erst recht für einen Bundesligaspieler, der Millionen verdient, ist es nicht selbstverständlich, sich jeden Tag den Arsch aufzureißen, auf den Platz zu gehen, sich maximal anzustrengen, 100 Prozent zu geben für seinen Club, für die Fans, die der Club ja sind, für seine Mannschaft, für sich selber. Das schließt sich doch nicht aus. Du brauchst doch jede Mannschaft. Wenn du Erfolg haben willst, brauchst du eine gesunde Mischung. Aber jeder sollte doch alles geben. Auch der Feingeist auf dem Platz sollte nach dem Spiel vom Platz gehen. Und ich habe auf meine Art alles gegeben. Was du natürlich brauchst – vielleicht hilft uns das jetzt auch weiter – ist eine gute Mischung. Und die hatten wir in der letzten Saison hier definitiv nicht.
Also eine Mischung an Spielertypen oder eine Mischung an Persönlichkeiten?
Eine Mischung an Persönlichkeiten, die Verantwortung übernehmen. Aber eine Persönlichkeit ist für mich dann auch nur einer, der für seinen Club, für seinen Arbeitgeber, für sein Team, für sich selber, für die Fans dann eben auch bereit ist, immer wieder alles zu geben. Es sind ja viel zu viele Pseudo-Profis auf dem Platz. Ein Profi wirst du ja nicht, indem du einen Vertrag unterschreibst und indem du viel Geld verdienst. Ein Profi bist du durch dein Verhalten. Hier bin ich allerdings bei ihnen auch. Die Mischung im letzten Jahr, die stimmte nicht. Wir hatten zu wenige Führungsspieler. Wir hatten sicherlich auch zu wenig Geschwindigkeit vorne. Wir hatten zu wenige Spieler, die vorne ein 1 gegen 1 auflösen können. Wir hatten zu wenige Spieler, die Verantwortung übernommen haben. Wir hatten zu wenige Spieler. Wir hatten sie. Nicht falsch verstehen. Wenn das jetzt jemand hört, sollen die das auch richtig verstehen. Wir hatten sie. Aber Spieler, die wirklich alles gegeben haben. Wir hatten sie. Aber zu wenig. Da hoffe ich natürlich auch, dass das in der nächsten Saison wieder besser wird. Bin ich optimistisch.
Ich glaube, mit dieser Hoffnung sind sie jetzt gerade hier im unmittelbaren Umkreis nicht alleine. Da hat ja auch Huub Stevens gerade in seiner Zeit als Interimstrainer sehr vielsagende Andeutungen gemacht. Und ich glaube, auf die letzte Saison bezogen wäre die Frage, die sie gestellt haben, gar nicht so rhetorisch wie jetzt im Allgemeinen bezogen. Ich hatte einen VfB Stuttgart, also einen Journalisten, der sich mit dem VfB Stuttgart befasst, in meinem Saisonrückblick zu Gast. Und der hat den Abstieg des VfB unter anderem darauf zurückgeführt, dass er gesagt hat, die soziale Komponente im Scouting würde seiner Meinung nach beim VfB vernachlässigt. Ich möchte jetzt nicht von Ihnen, dass Sie über den VfB urteilen, das brauchen wir nicht. Aber ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, trifft das vielleicht auch, wenn wir uns jetzt die letzte Saison anschauen, auf Schalke 04 zu?
Vielleicht. Vielleicht. So tief bin ich nicht drin. Aber ich habe da schon auch einen gewissen Ansatz. Früher hat es nur menschliches Scouting gegeben. Das heißt, die Scouts haben sich das Spiel angeschaut mit ihren Augen. Dann ist der Trainer hingefahren, dann ist noch jemand hingefahren. Und das war im Grunde nur ein reines, reines Augenscouting über Fußballwissende, über Erfahrung, welche Philosophie haben wir, hat man sich den Spieler angesehen. Ist im Idealfall auch nochmal zum Training gefahren, hat sich angeschaut, wie trainiert er. Weil im Training kannst du ganz viel sehen. Wenn ich den fünfmal im Training sehe und er ist zweimal stinkgefaul, dann weiß ich schon, der könnte für uns wahrscheinlich nicht geeignet sein. Das hat sich aber alles extrem entwickelt, über andere Sportarten. American Football, Rugby, Baseball, mir fällt jetzt nur ein, aus Moneyball. Da hat man dann stark angefangen, FC mit Jutland in Dänemark. Das Video-Scouting ist immer wichtiger geworden, aber auch das Scouting nach Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken. Wenn du in der heutigen Zeit nur eins machst von diesen beiden Dingen, also Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken oder nur Schauen, dann verhältst du dich dumm, weil du alle Ressourcen nutzen musst. Jetzt sage ich ja nur vielleicht. Dann musst du die Dinge zusammenbringen. Der Mensch programmiert ja auch immer noch. Der bleibt immer noch das Wichtigste. Du musst Zahlen, Daten, Fakten, Statistiken unbedingt nutzen, sonst handelst du fahrlässig. Aber wenn dadurch der Mensch in seiner Beobachtung, in dem, was er sieht, also live, weil die Zahlen sehen nicht, was geht in dem Spieler vor, ist er jetzt faul gerade, oder wie haut er sich rein gegen den genteilischen Spielmacher, welche Körpersprache hat der gerade, das kannst du nicht erfassen. Du musst im Grunde genommen in einem gesunden, guten Scouting beides tun. Beide Ressourcen nutzen, die Maschine, die Zahlen, die Daten, die Fakten, aber auch den Menschen.
Okay, und das ist dann quasi die Fußballpersönlichkeit und zu der gibt es ja aber auch noch eine Persönlichkeit, die sich auch neben dem Feld zeigt. Wie wichtig sollten dann im Scouting auch Einzigesprächen mit den Spielern sein oder eben dieses Kennenlernen? Ist das vielleicht noch so eine unterschätzte Fähigkeit, weil man sich heutzutage vielleicht an einem anderen Punkt schon für einen Spieler entscheidet und dann in eine andere Art von Gespräch geht?
Das hat Otto Rehagel ja mit seiner Beate damals schon immer vorbildlich gemacht, dass die alle Neuzugänge auch persönlich kennengelernt haben. Ich hoffe, es machen heute auch noch alle, weil letztendlich ist auch in diesem Bereich für mich Face-to-Face immer noch wichtiger als Facebook, weil nur wenn ich Menschen in die Augen schaue, so wie jetzt bei Ihnen, dann kann ich dann, wenn die Augen der Spiegel zur Seele sind, das kann ich nicht durch Zahlen, Daten, Fakten sehen. Das kann ich nur in einem persönlichen Gespräch. Indem ich Fragen stelle, indem ich mich für ihn interessiere, da kommt dann schon einiges raus. Und wenn du erfahren bist und wenn du eine gute Menschen kennennisst hast, dann spürst du schon, macht er dir was vor oder? Also, die Persönlichkeit, der Charakter, immer noch das Wichtigste. Das heißt jetzt nicht, die müssen auf dem Platz schon Drecksäcke sein kann. Aber ich finde, dass sie sich nicht ausschließen, ein anständiger Mensch und ein guter Fußballer zu sein.
Jetzt bekommen sie ja zu dieser Saison hin, also in der letzten Saison war es so, dass sie durch eine Konstellation am letzten Spieltag, eine Niederlage von Köln sind, sie noch auf den ersten Platz in der Arme.
Nein, durch einen Sieg von uns in Bochum.
Genau. Und sie haben natürlich, das ist natürlich ihr Dreh, aber dazu gehörte noch eine Niederlage vom ersten Spieltag.
Aber ich sehe als Trainer immer alle Spiele zusammen. Wer hat wie viele gewonnen? Wer hat unentschieden gespielt? Wie viel? Und wer hat wie auch verloren?
Okay, da möchte ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht mit hinkriegen. Sie sind dann ins Halbfinale der A-Bundesliga gekommen, da dann gegen einen gewissen Verein aus der Nachbarschaft dann verloren. Und jetzt zur neuen Saison hin hat sich ein bisschen das umgesetzt, was Sie jetzt auch schon vorhin gesagt haben, wo Schalke ein bisschen nachlegen muss, nämlich auch Quereinsteiger zu ermöglichen. Also sie haben jetzt eine ganze Reihe von Spielern mit dazu bekommen. Waren Sie dann zum Beispiel auch bei jedem der verpflichtenden Gespräche mit dabei, um die da kennenzulernen?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Und wie verändert das Ihre Arbeit, wenn das nicht Spieler sind, wo Ihnen dann schon der U17-Trainer sagt, also ich habe den jetzt zwei Jahre bei mir gehabt, der tickt so und so, in den und den Bereichen müssten wir wahrscheinlich noch was tun. Wie verändert das Ihre Arbeit jetzt, mit so vielen Quereinsteigern in eine neue Saison zu gehen?
Es wird sehr spannend, weil in der Form hatten wir es noch nicht. Muss ich aber noch ein bisschen weiter ausführen? Das letzte Jahr, die Westdeutsche Meisterschaft, war überhaupt nicht zu erwarten. Es war mindestens so ein großer Erfolg wie die deutschen Meisterschaften 2016, 2012, 2015. Weil wir hatten im letzten Jahr – und damit trete ich meinen Jungs überhaupt nicht so nahe, weil die haben was Großartiges geleistet – hatten aber zwei sehr durchschnittliche Jahrgänge. Da war der BVB Köln und auch noch die eine oder andere Anwandschaften mehr. Also spielerisch individuell uns überlegen. Also das war eine großartige Leistung. Letztendlich haben wir mit dem ersten Platz in der Liga uns in der Liga vor dem deutschen Meister positioniert. Positiv gesehen. Also war das Halbfinale für uns eigentlich schon, poah, haben wir ja nie mit gerechnet und haben das auch gut gemacht. Letztendlich war Dortmund einen Tacken stärker, aber wir haben da schon recht gut mitgehalten. Und die sind ja hinterher auch verdienter deutscher Meister geworden in Stuttgart. Aber neue Saison, wir haben zwei Dinge getan. Wir haben diesmal so viele Quereinsteiger geholt, nicht nur, weil wir wieder mehr Unterstützung haben, sondern weil es einfach nötig war und ist. Denn die beiden Jahrgänge, der Jungjahrgang vom letzten Jahr, die werden ja jetzt in der neuen Saison Altjahrgänge. Und der Jahrgang, der jetzt hochkommt, also die neuen Jungjahrgänge, letztes Jahr B-Jung, sind auch eher durchschnittlich, sind schon gute Jungs dabei. Also auch da will ich keinen zu nahe treten. Wir halten viel von ihnen, aber deutlich schwächer als in den letzten 10, 12 Jahren. Und von daher waren wir jetzt einfach in der Pflicht, auszugleichen. Und auf der anderen Seite, das mussten wir tun, um auch weiterhin auf verschiedenen Ebenen mithalten zu können. Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch, um den einen oder anderen mehr zu haben, den wir über den Quereinstieg – es sind ja dann immer noch ein, zwei Jahre – da denke ich immer wieder Özil, Kolasinac und McKennie. Und es gibt mehr, die später dazugehört worden sind, dass wir dann auch da weiter erfolgreich dual fahren können. Nämlich Spieler, die schon lange bei uns sind und hochkommen und Spieler, die dazugekommen sind. Machen andere Vereine auch. Ist jetzt aber nicht aus einer neuen Philosophie geboren, sondern einfach den Umständen, aus den Umständen entstanden, weil wir das tun mussten.
Und wie hat sich da der Markt verändert? Das Thema hatten wir vorhin schon mal so kurz angeschnitten. Was jetzt eben darum geht, so Spieler, die eben erst 15, 16 Jahre alt sind, zu einem Verein zu holen. Merken sie da auch, dass sich was verändert hat?
Spieler werden definitiv immer eher an ihre Clubs gebunden. Das ist auch, da bin ich nicht so genau drin in den Regularien, aber das ist den Auflagen auch geschuldet. Das hat mit Ausbildungsentschädigungen zu tun, die inzwischen verstärkt gezahlt werden müssen. Das macht auch Sinn. Aber die Spieler sind deutlich eher gebunden, sodass es schon immer schwerer wird, auch Quereinsteiger zu holen. Das ist uns diesmal, das wird ja dann in den nächsten Jahren in der Form auch sicherlich nicht mehr so der Fall sein. Alle Vereine holen 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Spieler, bei uns sind es jetzt mal ein paar mehr. Das wird in den nächsten Jahren dadurch, dass wir jetzt beide Jahrgänge ausgeglichen haben und die Jahrgänge, die jetzt kommen, wieder stärker sind, wird bei uns sicherlich dieses Jahr in der Beziehung auch eine Ausnahme sein.
Verfolgen Sie solche journalistische Berichterstattung, wie Sie zum Beispiel die Football-Leaks zutage gefördert haben, dass man gesehen hat, bei Spielern, die minderjährig sind, darf ja noch kein Geld anteilig am Berater fließen. Und dann konnte aber nachgewiesen werden, dass es da Abmachungen gibt oder Konstellationen, indem man das dann zum Beispiel über einen Job, den man dann einem der Elternteile vermittelt, auffängt. Oder zum Beispiel, dass man sagt, am 18. Geburtstag gibt es auf einmal eine Überweisung. Oder dass es auch ganz andere Modelle gibt, wie zum Beispiel Manchester City, die sich eine Jugendschule, eine Fußballschule in Afrika quasi so zu eigen gemacht haben, dass jeder, der aus dieser Schule rausgeht, dass Manchester City mehr oder minder über dessen fußballerisches Schicksal verfügen kann. Verfolgen sie solche Berichterstattung und glauben sie, dass man da von Seiten der Verbände mehr reglementieren müsste? Es geht ja hier um junge Menschen.
Ja, es kommt immer darauf an, welche Interessen. Das Interesse des einzelnen Menschen oder der Menschen sollte immer an erster Stelle stehen. Aber auch häufig stehen Machtinteressen darüber, Institutionen darüber, dass das das verfolge ich schon. Sprechen sie auch was bestimmtes an?
Naja, zum Beispiel eben diese Fußballschule von Manchester City. Es gab jetzt im Zuge von Kai Havertz, da wurde eben zum Beispiel so eine Überweisung fällig, ohne dass ich jetzt die Originaldokumente natürlich gesehen hätte. Ich gebe da jetzt nur die Berichterstattung des Spiegels wieder. Aber wir hatten eben solche Fälle auch innerhalb Deutschlands, auch zum Eintracht Frankfurt wurde da auch fast schon in Anführungszeichen Opfer eines solchen Falles, weil ihnen auch ein Spieler vermittelt wurde, bei dem im Hintergrund dann Geld floss, was aber der Verein erst im Nachhinein raus war.
Wo fließt denn kein Geld? Sagen Sie mir mal, ein Verein in Deutschland, wo kein Geld fließt, der dann den Leistungszentrum hat oder der Bundesliga ist.
Naja, wenn Sie jetzt einen 16-jährigen Spieler von wo auch immer zu Schalke holen, dann sollte ja da erstmal kein Geld fließen. So sind doch die Akte in Regularien.
Jetzt bin ich nicht derjenige, der für solche Dinge bei uns zuständig ist, aber ich kann mir das fast gar nicht vorstellen, dass das Geld irgendwo keine Rolle spielt. Ich bin aber bei Ihnen, es ist teilweise uferlos geworden, wie im großen Fußball auch. Also es gibt sicherlich Vereine, da gibt es schon für U19-Spieler, vor allem in England auch, da gibt es sicherlich, da gibt es schon Monatsgelder von 40.000, 50.000 Euro. Ich weiß jetzt nicht bei den ganz jungen, was da passiert, bin ich nicht exakt im Bild, sonst würde ich mich da auch klarer formulieren. Es gibt sicherlich auch Vereine, die in Deutschland schon überdimensional Gehälter zahlen im älteren Jugendbereich, sag ich jetzt mal so. Kann ich irgendwo verstehen, auf der anderen Seite nicht, gehe ich auch nicht so mit, wenn ich mal gefragt werde, was ein Spieler hier bei uns betrifft, weil ich einfach glaube, der Markt ist da, ein dummer Ausdruck für, wenn Menschen beteiligt sind, das Geschäft ist da, der Markt ist da. Es wird unglaublich viel umgesetzt im Fußball, halte ich aber nicht für sinnvoll, gerade im Jugendbereich nicht, weil ich glaube, dass die werden sowieso schon genug hochgejubelt. Und wenn du das Talent in den Vordergrund stellst und nicht mehr das Anstrengen und den Einsatz und dafür alles tun und wirst dann auch noch so hochbezahlt, so exorbitant hochbezahlt, kann das leicht Motivation töten. Aber ich bin zwar ein Fußballer-Romantiker, aber auch nicht blauäugig. Also ich weiß schon, dass Fußball im Jugendbereich definitiv auch eine sehr große Rolle spielt.
Also Sie meinen Geld im Jugendbereich?
Ja klar. Alles andere ist ja weltfremd und das weiß auch jeder und die bewegen sich dann, aber man bewegt sich natürlich dann im Bereich der Legalität. Da gibt es Auflagen dafür und da muss ja auch alles nachgewiesen werden. Also da machen Vereine jetzt nichts Illegales. Zumindest nicht soweit ich weiß.
Okay, ich könnte noch ganz lange mit Ihnen sprechen, aber so langsam muss ich Sie dann doch mal auch wieder an Ihre Saisonvorbereitung lassen. Sie sprechen in Ihrem Buch am Schluss noch die generelle Wertschätzung von Nachwuchstrainer im deutschen Fußball an und auch das Zertifizierungssystem, das der DFB und die DFL zusammen etabliert haben, um eben den deutschen Nachwuchs zu fördern. Wo, glauben Sie, steht Deutschland in seiner Entwicklung? Was fehlt noch, um den Bereich des Juniorenfußballs, des Nachwuchsfußballs, hin zum Leistungs- und Profifußball zu verbessern?
Ich glaube nach wie vor, dass wir immer noch zur unteren Weltspitze gehören. Mit der Zertifizierung meinte ich, grundsätzlich fand ich die gut. Wobei sich jeder Trainer, jeder Mitarbeiter und permanent sowieso hinterfragen sollte, wie wir besser werden. Die Frage muss man sich persönlich und als Gruppe jeden Tag stellen. Der Grundgedanke der Zertifizierung war, sicherlich auch Unterstützung und Ansätze zu geben. Es waren viele Dinge dabei, die hilfreich waren. Aber in einem Bereich hat es dazu geführt, zu sehr zu einer Vereinheitlichung. Jeder Mensch ist anders, jedes Unternehmen ist anders, jeder Verein ist anders. Das hat, um es schnell und einfach zu formulieren, etwas zu einer Vereinheitlichung geführt.
Weil man gewisse Punkte erfüllen musste, um das Zertifizieren zu bekommen.
Alle wollten diese drei Sterne, drei Sterne, drei Plus, haben. Alle haben sich sehr an diesen Katalog gehalten, um die drei Sterne zu bekommen. Dabei kannst du dich und dein eigenes Leben, deine eigene Philosophie, deine eigene Idee so ein bisschen verlieren. Das hat dann sicherlich auch dazu geführt, dass zu sehr alle nach dem Gleichen gestrebt haben, mit allem das Gleiche wollen. Da geht auch ein bisschen Kreativität, geht auch wieder ein bisschen, ja eine eigene Philosophie haben, geht ein bisschen verloren. Könnten Sie die Frage nochmal wiederholen, weil das ist die Schwerste, wo wir noch…
Genau, also wenn Sie zum Beispiel sagen, dass Deutschland noch in der unteren Weltspitze stehen, was das angeht, dann wäre jetzt die erste Anschlussfrage erstmal, wer ist denn da für Sie top? An wem könnte man sich denn orientieren?
Ja, sehr spannend. Gerade in Europa sind Spanien und Portugal, natürlich auch England und Frankreich. Warum, weshalb, ob das Migrationsgründe hat oder nicht, bin ich nicht so tief da drin. Da spielen natürlich viele Dinge auch eine Rolle. Es hat sehr viel mit Jahrgängen zu tun auch. Das wird man auch noch sehen. Jetzt der U21-Jahrgang, der gilt als sehr stark. Die kommenden Jahrgänge sind nicht ganz so stark. Und wenn Jahrgänge nicht ganz so stark sind, deswegen kann man dann auch nicht verallgemeinern und sagen, ja, da sind wir, da trainieren wir nicht gut genug. Die Ansätze müssen wir natürlich haben und verfolgen, uns immer weiter verbessern zu wollen oder auch zu sagen, das haben wir nicht so gut gemacht. Aber es hat schon mit Jahrgängen zu tun. Ich glaube, das Wichtigste wird sein, dass wir wieder die Spielintelligenz und die Technik in den Vordergrund stellen, aber auch Anstrengungsbereitschaft, Einstellung, dass wir diese Dinge mindestens auf einer Höhe mit Talent vielleicht sogar darüber stellen. Weil vieles ist auch hier bei uns zu leicht geworden. Und wenn du dich nicht mehr anstrengst, um irgendwas zu erreichen, dann wirst du. Und wenn du nur gelobt wirst für Intelligenz und Talent und für deine Fähigkeiten statt für Anstrengungsbereitschaft, für Wille, für Arbeitsmoral, für üben, üben, üben, üben, dann bleibt vieles auf der Strecke. Das ist für mich ein ganz wichtiger Faktor. Gerade hier bei uns in Deutschland, weil in Deutschland geht es uns, Gott sei Dank, immer noch im Schnitt verdammt gut. Vielleicht ist ein bisschen der Hunger auf der Strecke geblieben, beziehungsweise die Förderung des Hungers.
Wenn ich dann allerdings gucke, wo es noch Hunger gibt, dann sehe ich eine zweite Entwicklung, die aber dann irgendwie damit auch zusammenhängt, nämlich dass wir neue Trainerbiografien auch haben, also dass wir angefangen vielleicht mit Thomas Tuchel als jemand, der quasi dem Fußball fremd war, in dem Sinne, dass er keine Profifußballkarriere hatte, aus dem Jugendbereich es schafft, in der Bundesliga zu landen. Und davon haben wir jetzt ja eine ganze Reihe von erfolgreichen Trainerkarrieren. Und es scheint so zu sein, als wäre das auch dann Antrieb für viele andere Jugendtrainer. Ist es jetzt, dass wir eben zum Beispiel einen Julian Nagesmann, einen Thomas Tuchel, einen Florian Kohfeldt und wie sie alle heißen, dass wir die alle bis in die erste Bundesliga mitverfolgen durften, ist das jetzt Ausdruck dafür, dass es gerade eine goldene Trainergeneration gibt? Oder ist es vielleicht nicht auch ein Symptom dafür, dass dem Nachwuchsbereich das Renommee fehlt, dass solche Trainer, ohne jetzt die persönlich zu meinen, aber quasi diese Art von Trainer sagt, mir genügt es im Nachwuchsbereich, nachhaltig so wie sie vielleicht mal für 20 Jahre Arbeit zu machen?
Ja, jeder weiß und kennt die Wichtigkeit. Das wird häufig auch ausgesprochen. Aber Wertschätzung äußert sich über verschiedene Ebenen. Das Wertschätzung kann man formulieren, kann man ausdrücken. Aber es lässt sich auch über eine entsprechende Bezahlung und eine interne Wertschätzung darstellen. Und da ist der Nachwuchstraining – ich spreche nicht von mir, das hat aber auch 20 Jahre gedauert, bis ich mich mal aus dem Radar schiebe. Aber das war ja gewollt. Also das ist ja keine Klage.
Aber auch bei Ihnen wollte Rudi Assauer damals das Gehalt wieder reduzieren, als Sie nach Ihrer Co-Trainer-Tätigkeit wieder als U19-Trainer angefangen haben. Da haben Sie sich dann gegenverwehrt. Aber das zeigt ja quasi die Denke, dass eben dieser Job weniger wert ist, tatsächlich finanziell gesprochen.
Ja, das ist so. Ich kenne ja auch so ein bisschen die läufigen Zahlen. Das ist definitiv so. Auf der anderen Seite ist ein Grund natürlich der finanzielle Aspekt, dass viele heute ganz schnell nach oben wollen, weil die Fleisch-Stöpfe, die sind nur oben, und es wird eben dem Profibereich exorbitant bezahlt. Und das ist ja auch verständlich. Geld ist flüssige Energie, betone ich ja immer wieder. Sollte nicht an erster Stelle stehen im Leben, ist aber wichtig. Deswegen kann ich das auch nachvollziehen. Viele streben dann eben sehr schnell auch in die Öffentlichkeit, weil du dann eben die entsprechende Aufmerksamkeit medial, die entsprechende Wertschätzung eben bekommst. Deswegen kann ich das nachvollziehen, dass viele Trainer das machen. Das muss aber jeder für sich selber entscheiden. Aber die Wertschätzung ist nach wie vor nicht stark genug ausgeprägt. Da kann man darüber reden, häufig wird es formuliert, aber man kann es auch zeigen durch sein Verhalten, indem die Vereinsbosse sich entsprechend verhalten. Oder kann man sich was einfallen lassen, das ist nicht immer nur die finanzielle Schiene. Es sind viele Trainer-Talente dabei, große Talente, auf die sie jetzt genannt haben, plus auch der eine oder andere mehr. Das ist richtig so. Die sind auch richtig gut. Das, was ihnen fehlt, ist Erfahrung. Und Erfahrung kriegst du nur durch Erfahrung. Und deswegen muss jeder Verein sich das sehr, sehr genau überlegen. Ich hole einen dieser hochtalentierten, jungen Trainer, dann weiß ich, was der hat, weiß aber auch genau, was er nicht hat. Und für schwierige Situationen, wenn es richtig, richtig schwer wird, brauchst du Erfahrung.
Aber Sie würden ausschließen, dass wir Sie noch mal als Cheftrainer in der Bundesliga sehen. Sie hatten ja zweimal die Möglichkeit nach Slomka und nach Di Matteo und beide Male haben Sie gesagt, nein, danke.
Ausschließen würde ich das nicht. Es ist aber nicht in meinem Lebensplan. Aber ausschließen definitiv nicht. Ich betone ja immer wieder, dass ich das, was ich mache, sonst könnte ich das auch nicht so lange. Das können Sie nicht so lange. Ein Job, der so viel, jetzt mache ich das bis zur Rente und bin froh, wenn das endlich vorbei ist, da verstehe ich viele Menschen. Es kommt ja auch darauf an, in welcher Zeit ist man groß geworden und wie waren die Lebensumstände und und und. Aber im Moment würde ich es eher noch so sehen, dass ich für mich den größeren Sinn in meiner jetzigen Aufgabe sehe. Da bin ich dann ganz bei Viktor Frenkel, einem der größten Psychologen aller Zeiten. Ich glaube, es war der Begründer der Logotherapie, der gesagt hat, der Mensch wird nur etwas durch die Aufgabe, die er zu der Seinen macht. Heißt aber nicht, dass ich irgendwann nicht mal sage, also ausschließend tue ich es nicht.
Sehr gut. Jetzt habe ich meinen Aufmacherzitat. Nein, Quatsch, so funktioniert der Rasenfunk nicht. Herr Elgert, ich danke Ihnen sehr, gebe alles nun hier auf. Die Erfolgsstrategien vom Trainer der Weltstars ist das Buch, was Sie geschrieben haben, zusammen mit dem Journalisten Kai Psotter. Es ist erschienen im Ariston Verlag und hat uns unter anderem dieses schöne Gespräch beschert. Vielen Dank, Herr Elgert.
Ja, ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen für das spannende Gespräch. Viele schwierige Fragen.
Das ist ein bisschen mein Markenzeichen.
Aber das sollte auch so sein. Ich kann Ihnen eins sagen, das hat mich richtig gefordert. Danke auch dafür.
Okay, das freut mich. Danke, dass wir hier in Ihre Kabine rein durften. Bis auf bald, hoffentlich.
Ja, alles Gute und nochmals herzlichen Dank Ihnen, nur für Ihre Zukunft. Das ist von Herzen das Allerbeste.
So endet unser Gespräch mit Norbert Elgert. Wir hoffen, ihr hattet euren Spaß an dieser Unterhaltung. Lasst uns gerne Feedback da unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder über alle sozialen Kanäle, die euch so zur Verfügung stehen. Ihr könnt natürlich auch an der Verlosung teilnehmen. Solltet ihr Supporterinnen oder Supporter sein oder vielleicht in unsere anderen Formate reinhören. Es gibt noch die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz, da sprechen wir über den vergangenen Bundesligaspieltag bzw. wir haben jetzt auch Sendungen zur Frauen-WM und zur U21-EM produziert. Es gibt noch weitere Tribünengespräche, zum Beispiel mit Richard Goltz über 21 Jahre Bundesliga-Fußball, mit Thomas Bräuch über dessen Karriere, aber auch zeitlose Themen wie zum Beispiel der FIFA-Prozess, von dem man wieder erstaunlich wenig hört aktuell. Dabei laufen da immer noch ein paar Verhandlungen in New York. Auch das könnt ihr euch vielleicht reinziehen. Und es gibt noch den Rasenfunk Kurzpass für kürzere Sendungen. Vielleicht ist da ja auch was für euch mit dabei. Wir freuen uns in jedem Fall, wenn ihr dem Rasenfunk treu bleibt, wenn ihr vielleicht diese Folge auch weiterempfehlt und uns bewertet bei iTunes und den ganzen Plattformen, die es gibt. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis hoffentlich bald mal wieder im Rasenfunk. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.